this is Jocko podcast number 375 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
when Aziz and I reached the hills Peak
kids playing on the ladders and Diving
platforms scattered
as we neared the pool the only sound
other than our footsteps came from the
gusting wind
amid the Eerie quiet I noticed a cable
suspended from one of the middle diving
platforms about seven and a half meters
above the pool
the cable made of steel
barely swayed in the Wind
it ended in a slipknot noose
I've witnessed many public executions
here Aziz said
some were hanged
some were thrown off the towers like
garbage and died on the concrete floor
and not always immediately
after the Soviets left Afghanistan
following nine years of war the
difficulty of pumping water up to the
top of the hill to fill the pool wasn't
worth the effort for a nation with
little interest in training athletes for
international competition when the
Taliban seized control of Afghanistan
they found a use for the empty pool
Aziz and I descended the ladder into the
pool's deep end
the width spanned 25 meters the wall was
riddled with bullet holes the size of
762 bullets
they were head high of a person on their
knees
and there had to be thousands of holes
I crossed to the shallow end
stepping around puddles left by the
latest rain and observed the same
pattern of bullet holes in that wall
they were the height of the head of a
kneeling child
I pulled my Leatherman Tool for my pants
pocket
with the pointed pliers I dug into a few
of the holes
I removed two bullet jacket remains and
looked down at them in my hand
two symbols of the taliban's hatred of
innocent people
of unimaginable evil
I slid the jacket remains into my pocket
I didn't want to forget the anger I felt
standing next to those bullet holes
Aziz knew this place would show me why
his family was so caught up in our
presidential election
my home country was the land of the free
theirs was now becoming one
they needed us to help bring that
freedom to completion for them and for
future generations of afghans
I returned to that pool The Killing pool
I came to call it numerous times during
my deployments
I would sit in the breeze and the quiet
and the eeriness
and stare at that steel cable
and the bullet holes
I imagined the faces of innocent people
of the women and kids especially killed
there only because they tasted freedom
and discovered a joy so rewarding that
they didn't want to go back to their old
lives of Oppression
they couldn't go back
no matter the cost
and that right there is an excerpt
from the opening of a book the book is
called saving Aziz
and it's written by Chad robicho
and Chad is a former Force Recon Marine
who also serve as a military contractor
and in those roles he deployed to
Afghanistan eight times
he was eventually diagnosed with PTSD
which ended his deployments overseas
until years later during the American
withdrawal from Afghanistan
his former interpreter Aziz who you just
heard about his friend his brother in
arms needed to be saved from the Taliban
and when that happened
Chad had to go again into an unstable
environment to do the right thing
to save his friend
and save many others
and it's an honor to have Chad with us
here tonight to share his story Chad
thanks for coming down man man thanks so
much for having me on I listening to
read that of like Phil chills uh I mean
I've wrote it but just sit here and you
read it just like I'm picturing myself
like with the Leatherman Tool digging in
that wall yeah I remember I know we've
been we've been trying to do this
podcast for a long time
um you know you're a jiu jitsu guy I'm a
jiu jitsu guy
I I know actually you run an
organization called The Mighty Oaks and
there's been a few times I'm friends
with Matt there's been a couple times
where I've had to utilize you guys I've
called you guys when I got re people
would reach out to me that were having
serious issues and I would I've reached
out to Matt a few times to get support
so appreciate that and we'll get into
that later yeah but uh I'm glad I
finally got you down here man I'm glad
to find me here it's a we were talking
earlier it's always you know you wait
till the right time and I feel like
right now is the right time anyway so
I'm super happy to be here today right
on man
um let's let's before we jump into the
book
let's start at the beginning this is how
you how you became how he became Chad
robichaux am I saying that right Robo
show ER yeah you got it cool cool good
guess gotta come all the way to San
Diego to get somebody to say Robo show
right
so where were you born I was born in
Southern Louisiana uh good road show so
there's a rubber show there yeah yeah
I'm gonna say Southern Louisiana I mean
like mud between your toes swamps by you
so if you've seen Swamp People that's my
family uh so yeah and is that where you
grew up too that's where I grew up I
grew up in a town called Raceland
Louisiana really small town uh and runs
on The Whole Town's built in this one by
you called Bayou Lafourche which runs
down to the to the to the to the gulf um
and what are people doing there for a
living mostly fishing uh forming forming
and fishing uh shrimping so my
grandfather on one side bailed hay uh
and just mode mowed pastors and bailed
hay my grandfather on the other side was
a commercial cat fisherman since he was
a boy and so all of my family's first
jobs were skinning catfish in a catfish
Market my first job was getting catfish
I remember being you know going out and
trying to me and my cousins uh doubling
up on a on a bale of a 50-pound bale of
hay
um on one side of the family and then
the other side was uh was getting
catfish yes so so uh what did your mom
and dad do for a living so my dad uh so
my mom was a florist and my dad was uh
he was he was a marine and but he ended
up being in working in oilfield so my uh
my family actually has 84 years of
service and right now I guess there's a
book out that I hadn't tracked down yet
of Fred robichow who's my uh Uncle my my
grandfather's brother who served in
World War II as an infantryman in an
army and uh and as his book out that I'm
trying to track down so if anybody knows
it let me know but um but yeah so my
grand so World War II Korea my father
was the first Marine in our family
served as infantryman in Vietnam and
then uh and then myself and and both my
sons of Marines so so long history of
military and our family so when you were
growing up was your dad around when you
were growing up yeah uh well
they got divorced when I was seven
um and uh and then he was in and out of
my life I lived back and forth with my
mom and my dad and my grandparents so I
lived a pretty dysfunctional kind of
childhood bouncing back and forth my uh
my father never got help after Vietnam
in fact my father uh
join the Marine Corps
um if people look at the Vietnam draft
like you the Marine Corps didn't draft
people you had to volunteer for the
Marine Corps so my father was driving
the high school uh and goofing off with
his best friend in the passenger seat
and hit the back of a garbage truck on
the way to school kills his best friend
and then uh goes to the Marine Corps
Recruiting office and join some Marine
Corps to go to Vietnam and so that's how
my dad went into Marine Corps probably
already a pretty broken person had those
experiences Vietnam never got help and
uh so a lot of alcohol women a lot of
physical violence me and my my brother
um that were the kind of subjects of
that physical abuse I remember him
beating my mom watching him beat my
stepmom eventually but always it was
always targeted on me and my brother he
was a year older than me and uh so part
of joining the military was
because it's kind of weirdest Paradox of
wanting to follow my dad's footsteps but
also wanting to use that as a way to
escape from the childhood that I lived
in and uh I remember I was grew up in
martial arts so
um lifelong athlete started when I was
five years old in Judo and traditional
Jiu Jitsu so my brother and I were like
really close through that we bonded
through that and I remember we were
about 13 and 14 years old and we were
always playing in the swamps and bayous
and playing military and we were like we
could join the military one day and
Escape like get a fresh start escape
this lifestyle and we were watching them
you probably remember this is
this was like uh so it would have been
this would have been like 19 like uh
eight late 80s there was this Navy SEAL
video these guys let down the Strand and
they were like they like raided The
Strand oh yeah the recruiting video yeah
the recruiting video called be someone
special yeah that's it yeah have you
seen it in the last 20 years no but I
bet it looks really cheesiness so it's
so absolutely terrible it captured me
100 yeah I was like we've seen that
video and we were like and then I
remember there was this picture uh of
this Navy SEAL he's coming out of the
water he's got a booty hat on seaweed
hanging off him twin 80s on his back and
M16 and I'm like I want to do that but I
don't want to join the Navy and uh you
know it was the one thing was I think it
was my dad the one thing my dad was
always just like Angry dysfunctional
human being but the one thing that
always made him proud and happy was the
fact that the United States Marine and I
was like if that can make that guy happy
I want a piece of that and and uh so I
started there was these books like uh
men with green faces and I started
reading these Vietnam books and then I
had found these uh books from a third
Recon and third forestry kind of Vietnam
and I was reading those books just
became infatuated become a Recon Marine
so 13 my brother's 14 we start training
and about a year into that my brother
was shot and killed and uh it was
devastating how was he Shawn killed he
was uh he had we so we had a broken
family so he had a another brother that
was 11 from the other side of the family
they got an argument my brother had a
fire poker and was trying to knock a gun
out of his hand he had the other kid had
he was 11 years old had a 20 gauge
pointed at him and uh and when he either
intentionally or unintentionally I don't
know but Point Blank Range with 20 gauge
shotgun to chest and he died instantly
um so he was on the phone so someone
heard or heard it all on the phone he
was holding the phone and had a fire
poker
and uh and this is when you're 13 years
old there's 14 when this happened okay
yeah so we were
you know we when we were all you know
that 13 to 14 years old that's when we
started running and we were swimming uh
watching those videos and uh and we uh
you know for me that was like the
closest person to my life at that time
so I went into real deep isolation my
father my stepmother who was the
biological mother of my brother couldn't
handle loss of her son she went moved
back with her parents my father moved to
Africa in an oil field job he didn't
want to deal with her and uh I had a 20
year old sister and so the Two of Us by
the time I was right right about 15
years old I found myself living alone uh
with my sister trying to work I was
working on Roofing uh I was doing
putting shingles on houses and I was
trying to go to high school at the same
time and uh when I was 17 years old I I
knew I probably wasn't going to graduate
high school and I went to a Marine Corps
recruiter named staff sergeant Ronald
Brown I still remember his name almost
30 years later I mean most people
remember their recruiter's name because
they hate them uh I I I'm just thankful
to this dude I mean he he I told him my
situation I was just remember being real
real transparent with him about what my
life was like and how I wanted to go to
the Marine Corps and he helped me get in
the Marine Corps without even a high
school diploma I wasn't going to
graduate 1993. and how old are you I'm
17 at the time
did you you said you had you've been
doing Judo and traditional did you
wrestle too you know I I tried to
wrestle for two years we tried to start
a club at my high school but there was
not enough never enough people in the
team and so I wrestled but I never
competitively wrestled because we didn't
have enough people for our team uh and
it was mostly people from our Judo club
that was trying to put a wrestling team
together at a high school we just
couldn't get Southern Louisiana couldn't
get enough people together but this okay
I just wanted to catch that little uh
detail because I know you know like I
said you're just a guy I'm a jujitsu guy
you end up fighting all this stuff so I
just wanted to catch where that where
that started so you go to the Marine
Corps recruiter God bless the Marine
Corps and for every you know like you
said man for all these guys that get you
know screwed over by the recruiter
occasionally that recruiter is a
lifesaver for somebody and the and the
Marine Corps is a lifesaver for you who
who knows where my life would be right
now I mean I mean
I wasn't heading the right good
trajectory I wasn't like doing drugs or
anything like that I was still like very
disciplined in training martial arts I
was running like 50 60 miles a week a
week so I was running a lot and I'd go
swim I would go swimming so still I was
doing the right things but
like academically in school I was like
failing uh I was you know I was I was
not gonna graduate high school so this
guy put me on a infantry contract it
wasn't Recon contracts back then and uh
and I made him promise that I get my GED
when I finished infantry school and I
went through boot camp went to Repertory
school
so you show up to boot camp yeah you're
17 years old when are you 17 when you go
to boots 17 when I go to boot camp
that's freaking my 18th birthday was in
it was right here right here down across
the street wherever yeah
so I need is it a shock to your system
or are you just totally pumped for it I
was totally pumped for it I mean I mean
I mean it was something I had thought
about obviously for a long time and uh
and I remember just being like
it's weird how you can remember certain
things but I remember like standing like
literally standing on those yellow
Footprints thinking that like
everything that's behind me like this is
a chance for me to
to do something uh because I was at that
I had my my childhood was so my my
stepfather like lots of physical abuse
in my life I felt free I felt like a
sense of Freedom that I wasn't held back
by like my stepfather my dad like it was
just like this is for me I could do what
I want to with this and and I don't know
how the young naive age of 17 years old
that made a decision to embrace it and
uh and I just
put everything I could you know
graduated squad leader at boot camp I
got honor grad out of infantry school I
get to 29 Palms California and I'm like
I made this guy promise the Marine Corps
is not I have no contractual obligation
to get my GED but I'm like made this guy
promise I went to Copper Mountain
College in 29 poems got my GED all these
years later I have NBA and always joke
when I'm speaking I'm like I can't spell
NBA but I got one but uh you know like
the Marine Corps really game and now go
speak at Marine Corps boot camp for
eight years now go every quarter right
here in San Diego and now I'm going to
Paris Island I've spoke to I spoke to
about half a million troops over the
last 12 years all you know a lot of them
at Marine Corps boot camp and and I tell
them about their experience like when
you stand them as yellow Footprints and
Marine Corps boot camp wherever you know
young service members and find
themselves and they raise their hand and
make that commitment it's it doesn't
matter like what color you are if you're
black white asian Hispanic it doesn't
matter if your dad was rich or poor or
you lived in a project or a trailer park
none of that matters like it's on you to
change the trajectory of your life for
better for worse and you have that
opportunity when you go there and uh and
none of your past matters anymore and uh
I like really had recognized that I had
that I had that drive to want to take
advantage of the opportunity and also
had this like like lingering like
commitment that me and my brother were
going to be recovering and uh and so I
went while I was in Francisco I tried
out for Recon I don't know why they let
us try out because they let us try out
and then the guys who passed it were
like yeah we're not taking anybody
that's not ncos and I sent this away and
uh so it was just maybe uh and then I
went back again past the second time
same thing happened and I went then I
went to uh and 21 Palms went to what's
called regimental State platoon which is
a surveillance Target acquisition
platoon it's a sniper platoon and uh
that was right after I got to 29 palms
and then I tried out a third time and
got picked up and so my first year in
the Marine Corps got a chance to go
become a Recon Marine so that was your
first year in the Marine Corps first
year in the Marine Corps which back then
it was you know really hard to do you
didn't have a contract you usually have
to be around a while and so I got I got
picked up and how come you got picked up
were you like physically just kicking
ass I was I was in really good shape I
mean I was like I'm super I'm small now
but I was like 120 pounds I was running
like I was only like 16 minute three
miles I was you know I was really good
in the water I was you know I grew up in
the bayous and water I never
competitively swam but I was just really
comfortable in the water and uh yeah
and uh you know I think I was just I
just wanted it so bad and uh and so
myself and a guy who went to boot camp
with named uh Mark Terrell who's
actually still in Marine Corps he's at
Gunner now which is not a gunny a gunner
which a combat advisor he's you know
Recon Warsaw and he's uh but we went
through it together uh me him and a guy
named Foster Harrington who's uh Foster
was killed in our on our first
deployment but uh
yeah so we all went through that
together and they were young guys too so
this was what year is this 1994. so I
went into 93 94. and then the Recon
school is that the one that's down in
Coronado yeah well it that they're still
running the Coronado but part of it's in
Coronado it used to be when I went it
was ewtg pack and I went right across
some buds but now it's uh headquartered
in Camp Hill on under the school of
infantry but you still do the amphithe
package down in Coronado but how long is
how long is the Recon school well it's a
it's a whole pipeline it's a year-long
uh so they go they go to What's called
they'll go to four weeks of infantry
school and then they go to uh they go to
What's called uh Mark Marines awaiting
Recon training and it's just like a
holding platoon that they just weed
people out through physical fitness uh
and then they have then they do brpc
which is basically kind of Prep course
which is three weeks and then they do a
basic Recon course which is 10 weeks and
what are you learning in the basic Recon
course uh
shooting shooting movements communicate
communication amphib all the amphib
stuff it's basically like a you're doing
all the core functional like things of
Recon Marines all the different uh
reconnaissance missions route reps
sporting reps
um Hilo Zone surf reps confirmatory
Beach reports gets all those kind of
those kind of with no equipment like
just the you know the lock the 550 core
getting tangled up in the service so all
that stuff and then a lot of Fitness uh
you could when you walk up when these
guys kids leave Recon school they can
communicate as good as any Communicator
probably better because they get more
equipment uh they should be able to do
all their uh basic like uh you know call
fire stuff and nylons uh and then they
they're patrolling a small unit
patrolling and they're going to rotate
through kind of like a Ranger school
where they'll go through like being a
point man to always being a team leader
so they're gonna get fragged during that
patrolling phase and now you're the team
leader and they'll do 10-day patrolling
phase Land Navigation is extremely
difficult both water and uh and land
yeah so it's it's it's it's extremely
difficult because it doesn't allow you
to dead reckon you have to pick up a map
and Compass terrain associate and and
run with gear uh or you're not going to
make the time Hamilton's a National
Treasure it is it really is that place
is freaking awesome it's awesome bigger
but
um so when you graduate BRC you go to
then you go you graduate on Friday and
then on Monday you're in pre-scuba you
do two weeks of pre scuba and then you
go to down to Florida for 10 weeks or
nine weeks of combat dive who teaches
that is it Marine Corps is that the Navy
course it's the Marine Corps one so
you're doing closed and open circuit um
so yeah the Navy courses the open
circuit course back in my day I did Navy
open circuit then I did a lower five
transition course but now they do the
whole combat dive course we're sort of
learning the you know insertion uh
really more the insertion of being able
to navigate uh on a large five that's
basically what they're doing and then uh
and then uh you do Sears school then
Free Fall school and then you go to
units so when the guy let's go to unit
now there's
19 20 years old then they're schooled
out there ready to deploy
and that is that what you did too you
went through all those schools I did but
I didn't do them all consecutive in a
pipeline like that so I went I went
through and then you wait around school
yeah probably like kind of your in your
day yeah well no you guys come out
diving we would come out dive but we
didn't go to jump school until after and
we only went to static line down in Fort
Benning with the US Army yeah and then
we got done with that eventually I
didn't get I didn't get free fall until
after my first platoon and now guys get
it they just get it in the pipeline
before they even get their get their
bird they get the free fall school yeah
same thing with me in in the meantime
what's your per didn't you get married
when you were young as well oh yeah we
me and Kathy met when I was right before
Recon school so we met 17 and 18. our
first dates was like the on Coronado
Beach like like her come coming down to
see me on there like because you don't
get any days off there and you get you
get like we got like I think two
weekends off and then you gotta write up
you got 80 page Patrol right on those so
like so she came down to see me on those
weekends and I remember we actually
fell asleep together on the beach out
there right uh but uh that's uh you know
that was
that was how we started dating and then
a year after we started dating we got
married so when she was 18 and you're
19. yeah that's true we all got married
so we got married yeah and so she's been
through all of it
yeah yeah that's uh and that's awesome
though you guys are still together
um so so now you're you're doing this
and then what's what are you going on
deployment what are your deployments
like no it's not 93 I mean uh I went in
93 and so this was like you know finish
this training in 94. there's no
deployment so actually did you go on an
ARG deployment or something no we do
we're my my unit was doing uh was mainly
doing the uh jtf6 missions
across border here you know right across
the border from where we're at in Mexico
we were doing uh jtf6 counter-rocotics
missions uh that's primarily what my
unit was doing when I was on active duty
and then after that first four years I'm
like man we're not doing anything right
now I want to go
be an officer so I went to the reserves
I went to third Force Recon in reserve
so you do your first hitch uh you get
done with all this schooling were they
pissed when you said you were gonna go
reserves or were they downsizing at this
time yeah I don't think it didn't seem
like they really cared yeah they offered
me a school and uh and an ini Billet at
in Reno which was the instructor
inspector instructor Billet at fourth
fourth Force Recon it was not really
that wasn't really pushing guys to stay
in so you make a decision you're gonna
get out or go to the reserves yeah go to
school
be coming off and then you can come back
in as an officer yeah that was my that
was my plan and that way you'll be able
to financially take care of your family
did you have a kid yet yeah we had a
hunter hunter was born my oldest he was
born yeah I'm from Louisiana like we
started earlier
they thought you were old and you had a
kid at 19. they're like what's wrong
with you what are you waiting for oh
yeah that was the pressure from remember
Mom saying you can be getting married
like okay she's pregnant like like yeah
so when you get out what are you gonna
do now so now you're out you got a kid
you're in the reserves and this is when
you you become a uh a police officer
right yeah yeah I mean I was I was
trying to find work like uh to go
through college I mean uh and this this
may sound stupid it was I didn't sign up
for the uh the GI bill you have to sign
up for it oh that's right so I mean I'm
in boot camp you said no I'm in boot
camp I'm the one idiot that said no
right and I'm like I didn't even
graduate high school like 100 bucks a
month was like that's a tenth of your
paycheck like
yeah so what happens is the GI Bill
that you pay well probably the same as
when when you went through and I went
through it's different now I think but
it was a hundred you pay 100 bucks a
month for a year yep and then after that
year when you get out whenever that is
they give you something like 40 grand
for school if you're in college and Chad
looked at that says no deal bro I want
my 100 bucks that's exactly right yeah
I'm the idiot that did it
you couldn't get back I tried yeah the
other thing is even if you don't use it
you can give it to your kids yeah so who
you are a stubborn bastard for you to be
like no I'm not doing it actually had a
drill instructor tell me it like like I
had talked told me in like two other two
or three other guys not to do it and uh
I don't know why I can't remember why
but I didn't and uh and and now I'm like
that is the stupidest decision
especially for me because I end up
getting get NBA which was expensive yeah
okay so you get out now you don't have
you got to go to college but you also
need a job you got a kid you got a wife
so how hard does it become a cop is it
is it a because right now there's
recruiting for cops it's a lot easier to
become a cop than it used to be because
the cops are having a hard time
recruiting people to be cops because
there's so much negative press uh what
was it like when you tried to become a
cop it was pretty easy I mean I'm you
know I'm going back to you know
Backwoods Louisiana and uh I cut it out
of the military so I'm coming off of
active duty Special Operations so like
not a lot of competition in a recruiting
pool and I was
I mean I was I thought I was about to
pull it off doing this I was teaching
swimming lessons and water survival for
the oil field at YMCA so him using them
some of the skills I have to teaching
little kids swimming lessons and uh
which my kids were the best
and then uh and then uh there was like
this water everybody goes in the oil
over they have the underwater egress for
like when you helicopter rollovers and
stuff like that so I gotta I got a
position at the YMCA to teach that for
the guys traveling in the oil field but
I just wasn't making enough money so I
was like man I gotta do something else
so I went to the jail and I was working
at the jail and uh and and Corrections
Facility like four days a week four
nights a week trying to do all this and
then um and then they offer me a
position to go to the police academy
and how long is the police academy like
three months something that wasn't long
how was it yeah it was pretty I mean I
was in such good shape at the time it
was pretty easy but actually I do
remember studying a lot though and you
had to take What's called the post uh
which is the state exam and uh so I
remember studying a lot I remember Kathy
like helping me study she was already
like tuned to that because you know the
military schools and doing flashcards
with me she's helping her rock on
speaker
yeah when uh is this are you back in
your hometown where you grew up when you
were doing this yeah I went back went
back to my hometown and uh so I
graduated to Police Academy and uh in
this department
um which is called St Charles Parish
which is where the New Orleans airport
is just like New Orleans is like this
kind of mesh of uh yeah
um you have Jefferson Jefferson Parish
and they don't have counties that
parishes so they have Jefferson Parish
St George Parish Orleans Parish that's
like kind of New Orleans area and so
they I graduated like I got the like
physical fitness and the high shooter
award at an academy and and uh so I had
so the the sheriff there offered me a
job to come I was looked really young
still and so they offered me a job to
come to St Charles Parish and work
undercover in the high school there damn
so fresh fresh out of fresh out of the
Marine Corps and go back to high school
and uh and uh so you did it I did it
yeah and so what did you do what do you
roll in there you're carrying a freaking
book bag
algebra book I remember walking through
the hall in a and a teacher like put his
hand out and I'm like and I had gum in
my mouth and I'm like
you know like last year I was doing
counter drug missions in Mexico that's a
four streak as a Porsche Recon team
leader and now I'm having to spit my gum
out for this teacher that's you know but
I I was I went the whole plan was for me
to go to school for like two weeks and
then leave the school and have those
relationships and uh I wasn't trying to
I wasn't my job wasn't to go bus kids it
was to just adults that were selling the
kids and so getting that Network and and
I did that for like four months and we
at the end of it we had like like uh
over 40 like a felony warrants that we
were able to pull up so it was pretty
pretty uh yeah it was pretty uh cool out
cool opportunity to do that did you was
that like an undercover gig do you have
a fake name and all that stuff yeah I
did I had a fake name and a fake
driver's license in Louisiana that you
get you know through the governor's
office and how old were you supposed to
be I was high school age I can't
remember exactly but uh like like 17
yeah yeah yep 17 and I wish that so they
had another kid in our task force that
played in a
I went to high school called Belle Chase
high school and he played for the and he
was like he played in college baseball
and then he went played uh baseball at
the high school bro like he was like he
had this story like my parents died and
and so the team came together and bought
him a glove and
he's like he's like ripping leather off
a balls what do you do like on a I was
hoping there was a wrestling team like I
could have like been smashing kids on
their face like stay tuned so like on a
Friday night when the kids are having a
party yeah you'd go yeah and uh I don't
know what book did I write it in I think
I wrote it in my book an unfair
Advantage we uh we we were at this party
and uh
I think it passed the period where I get
in trouble for this
but but we had this party in these guys
it was these you know all these high
school girls were like I'm like new the
new guy right so there's a high school
girls so it wasn't anything to do with
drugs or anything like that these guys
want to beat me up because their
girlfriends were like after me right
right so I'm at this high school party
and I got these guys wanting to beat me
up they were they were not kids or
adults and uh and so
I'm trying to leave and this guy takes a
swing at me and and I push the car door
and he hits this girl and uh and when
that happens I like grab the guy and
then someone shoots the back of the
truck because these are all you know
pretty bad people somebody shoots the
back of our truck and our uh the guy I
was with who was not an undercover guy
he was just like kind of like my cover
officer from another town he he like
stands up out of the top of a uh of a we
were in a forerunner there's a sunroof
he stands up and starts laying like a
base of cover fire at a high school
party like with a Glock just empties a
magazine everybody's running and then he
peels out of there
what was your fake name do you remember
your fake name well my first name I kept
my first name okay and then I changed my
last name to my son's name Hunter so
Chad so Chad Hunter yeah like dude don't
mess with Chad Hunter his buddies his
buddy's crazy so this guy the guy who uh
uh his last name was McKinney what was
his first name but he he so he comes
they come after me and they have like
they come after me they had between a
group of them they had an AK-47 and they
were coming after me so I'm picking up
this girl from school from high school
and these guys come I didn't have my gun
with me because it was in a car so these
guys try to jump me and I go to my car
and we and they and I grabbed my gun and
they come over top and getting this like
little altercation for my gun and that
and after that the whole thing was over
we ended up doing a massive arrest so
this guy uh
this guy this guy comes uh is there
looking for me now uh so they pulled me
out of being undercover we do this thing
so Benjamin McKinney's his name and so
last year I'm teaching your Jiu Jitsu
seminar and this guy comes up to me and
he goes do you know who I am and and
it's it's this guy Benjamin McKinney
he's like he's like I hope you don't
hate me and he like makes this big
apology to me and he's like his life's
like a good place right now he's like he
went to jail for this and uh you know
spent some time in jail and he's like
been following me for years now and he
like now he's like man I really look up
to what you're doing what you're doing
is amazing uh he's like yeah when I got
my ass beat don't worry it was a forced
recovery and I was only 14.
yeah yeah when you were so this is like
uh he was an adult though yeah yeah okay
he was like 18 19 or something like that
when how did you like being undercover
did you like that yes I did it it like
right away like I gravitated to that um
I don't like that stuff yeah I don't
like it I don't like I don't like I
don't like pretend yeah and
I just don't like that kind of thing and
and I always wanted to have like an
American flag on my chest like this is
me I'm American yep that's what we're
doing I was never suited for the other
side of things you know I just just not
part of my personality and even as I
think about like under even I guess the
at least in high school it doesn't seem
like there'd be a huge Threat Level
although apparently there was but it
doesn't seem like you'd have to get too
kind of complicated with your stories
and your Web of Lies that you're telling
is that is that super deep right it's
pretty shallow I had apartment my dad
like this old guy that worked at the
Sheriff's Office and he came in and
would pretend to be my dad every now and
then but another thing you know Lou
Rivera so he's uh he he lived like he
went to the same high school and we
found this out later he went to the same
high school and he knew about it and he
like lived in the street that he used to
buy crack off of
I don't know why like I never thought
about doing that it never aspired to
doing that but when I did it I kind of
liked it because I felt I felt like I
could always adapt to any environment
that was in like blend in with any group
of people like I could go you know rich
people poor people like I just blend
everywhere I go and that's just kind of
my personality so I felt like it really
worked in that in that world like really
I felt super comfortable doing that so
you got a good taste for for that type
of thing you know um which is cool now
you you had uh uh officer-involved
shooting too I did when you were a cop
what happened with that so I had just
got off of uh the undercover thing they
put me on patrol and uh and I went
through the I still had to go through
the whole like fto field training
officer thing and this guy wrist Marine
name uh Steve Stephen cantelli uh
trained me and a guy named him him and a
guy named Paul train me and then so I'm
I'm done with the fto and I'm working my
beat which which is like they have this
in the East Bank of New Orleans side
they had like these four beats and so I
was like the center one and the guy like
uh won over for me was the guy that
trained me Steve contelli and uh I was
just eating and I remember hearing a
call come over radio and uh Steve was
like a really composed like kind of just
very like solid guy and heard his voice
like something was wrong in the radio
system cut off we just got a brand new
radio system for the whole department
you know kind of Murphy's Law it shuts
off and uh and so I'm like man something
just inside me was like he needs help so
I like I remember speeding there and got
my lights in my car and uh and people
were like stopping in the road instead
of like pulling over and it was like
having to like I'm just being panicked
to get to him because I just felt this
imminence to get to him when I got to
where he was it was just like uh it
wasn't like a trailer park but it's like
modular homes and um and it was elevated
and there was about 30 people outside
the front like looking at this the porch
and Steve was on the porch uh elevated
porch with this woman and he's yelling
with her she I could see her trying to
get in the house and he's trying to hold
her back but he's still looking inside
and I come up on the porch and Steve is
this night time it's night time okay
yeah but I get about 30 people out front
and uh and uh Steve's like hey her
husband you're alone in your car yeah so
you're saying single person yeah so just
me and him there and uh and so Steve
says hey this this her husband just
barricaded himself in the back his name
was Russell Stebbins that we had been
there before he's he's barricaded
himself the back he's got a gun get her
off the porch so I I like to talk to her
she was arguing I just grabbed her and
and a bunch of men down at the bottom I
just pushed over to rail and a bunch of
men grabbed her and pulled her off her
kids were down there uh like uh I
wouldn't say toddler but like you know
uh maybe six seven-year-old kids down on
the ground uh looking up and you can
could tell they were like scared trying
to figure out what's going on and uh and
so I came back and when I when I turned
back around Steve put me in the doorway
he's like hey stand right here I'm going
to cover the window and and so he went
to the window where which is the back
room of this modular home so he couldn't
shoot out the window and I stood in the
doorway of this uh of the main of the
like right in front of his living room
to the rights of kitchen and the
catacorn across from me as a hallway and
in the category uh at the end of the
hallway is a mirror and so I kind of see
down the hallway
and I'm standing in there and I have a
I have my my glock I have a Glock uh 40
40 caliber pistol
um and uh and have it have it out and
when I seen him come into the window
that mirror he had his uh rifle kind of
against him and he was like barricading
himself and I could see him manipulating
the like press checking and I'm like I
just start you know yelling and I'm like
hey Put the Gun Down come out let's talk
about it he's like I want to see my wife
and you guys need to leave and I'm like
we're not leaving you need to put the
gun down I'm kind of talking like a like
a cop would like you train to do and
then um he and would provoked him to do
this but he came around the corner and
he had the gun over his shoulder not
like not like shoulder like the fire but
he had it over his shoulder with the
barrel Point towards me but I could see
his hand was by the trigger but not on
the trigger which is kind of weird that
he would do it like that and he was
pointing it to me but you know and
lethal force continuum like you could I
could have shot him right there but for
some reason I felt like
I still had control of the situation and
like this a guy that's arguing with his
wife he obviously been drinking there's
still dinner on the table there's a his
kids toys around the floor there's
family pictures like
you know you don't want to kill someone
unless you have to like I mean that
morning if somebody would ask me like
somebody I'm like yeah I'm freaking
gonna light him up but now in that
moment like the reality of it like man I
don't have to kill this guy right now I
can still control the situation
so I but I start yelling and I'm like
not like a cop anymore I'm like I'm
gonna [__] kill you like put your gun
down I'm gonna kill you and he's like
you put down your gun and he gets in
this all like verbal altercation back
and forth to me and he's he was uh six
three 230 pounds I know his height
weight so he's a I'm like 125 pounds and
uh and I've been training a lot I was
training a lot of the time in Muay Thai
and and Jiu Jitsu and I saw my
confidence level was probably like you
know I'm getting fights all the time as
a cop and and uh and so I decided to try
to disarm him so I walked I kind of
closed the distance on him with my gun
retained in tight and I grabbed the
barrel of his gun and pushed it away
from me and I kicked him in the nuts
like not like a football like kick but
like a push kick they'd like try to pull
the gun out of his hand and uh man like
nothing and the second time I kicked him
I must have like pulled my arm away from
me and he grabbed my wrist so now we're
like fighting over so you have his rifle
with your hand but he has your pistol in
his hand or your wrist your wrist in his
hands so neither one of you has control
full control over your Firearms that's
right and uh and so at that point I I
knew like he was not giving up and so I
just uh I turned my wrist over like to
break the grip and I'm like a scene like
Center Mass and I shot once and then I
then I pulled my gun and I shot five
more times so I shot like six rounds
like
pretty quickly uh and then I didn't even
realize Steve was behind me but he was
right over my shoulder he shot six times
we hit him 11 times I didn't drop the
round by the way always a good point to
make uh
but yeah but it was it was so close so
cinematic like and he He Turned hit his
knees and uh he looked back at me like
conversationally like he's like you
killed me and uh and then he like fell
over I pushed him down and pulled the
rifle underneath from underneath him and
um and I was trying to get his arms to
handcuff him and one of his wrists I
think when I when I shot him one of his
wrists went probably when I broke the
wrist grip it went in front of his body
and uh so it blew out his wrist so when
I went to grab his wrist to handcuff him
it was just like jello like I remember
just like getting I had like short
sleeves on and I felt I had like blood
all over me and he like I heard him
breathe out and uh you know he kind of
like exhaled and breathed his last
breath and uh and I handcuffed him and
uh we searched the house and heard all
kind of police you know sirens and
everything but it's coming like right
then and I remember looking back like
like right after when I was I looked
right back out and for some reason my
eyes went I want to like look back in a
I don't know what happened first if I
heard her scream or or or if I seen her
first but I just remember his wife like
screaming like the loudest like blood
curling scream and then I seen the kids
just like just like just stoic like it's
quiet and then um and then everybody got
there separated me and Steve and uh we
ended up getting a right thread to us
got the polygraph the whole interview
thing and then the next day uh
police chief called me up and was like
hey don't read the newspaper of course I
did and say cold-blooded murderer and
then underneath it's a really small
police say Justified and I went through
a long process of a way before grand
jury for second degree murder indictment
got cleared by the grand jury we got an
award from the uh the governor of uh
Meadow Valley award
um
we went through a lawsuit all the stuff
that goes along with something like that
and then I was just like super bitter
after that and uh at because of the way
the department handled it
I mean there's you know super political
no one wants to make a decision uh the
District Attorney's Office could have
like
not put us before Grandeur he was very
clear what happened but uh we uh that
was I had no interest in law enforcement
after that I was like pretty pretty
jaded
and so then was it back in the Marine
Corps well I mean I hung out I actually
went from Patrol and uh that incident
because of that award the chief had
promoted me the detective and so I'm
like
23 years old I've been I've been on you
know did my four years in Marine Corps
did one uh seven to eight months
undercover did a year on patrol and now
I'm putting the detective Bureau because
I just got this big award and uh and so
I did that for a little bit until 9 11
happened and then uh when 9 11 happened
you know it was I think everyone was
rushing back everybody reserves rushing
back to their unit I thought I was going
to deploy right away and uh
and uh we we didn't and so uh that I
don't remember that it was time the Air
Marshals went around recruiting at all
the reserve units because you had
Special Operations guys with top secret
clearances and so I was on that first I
wasn't that first wave of guys I went to
Air Marshals and uh did a little bit of
time there and then and then how long
how long did you do with the Air
Marshals just under two years it was it
was super cool at first then it became
really lame really fast what was the
number of Air Marshals there were before
9 11 and what was the number of Air
Marshals that were after around 45
before
um I think the number after uh number
now uh I I wouldn't know but at the time
they spun up from about 40 uh for a
little bit over 40 and about 2 000
pretty quick and uh and no you know I
got to give it to them the academy the
training like I went through the first
training was it was freaking good legit
it was legit like uh you know we had to
do the flexi stuff the Federal Law
Enforcement Academy stuff went down on
Artesia Mexico but the shooting package
was was the most competitive shooting
package I'd ever pistol shooting package
today we used to shoot that whatever
their Claw is TPC Tactical Pistol cores
I just remember some call that that we
called the air marshal and I don't know
who knows if some team guy just saw it
and whatever talk to somebody about it
but we had some and I forget what it was
but it was a it was a good tough you
know if you weren't on your game you you
could blow some of the shots which makes
sense obviously you're in an aircraft
with a bunch of people yeah and you only
have a pistol you want to be a freaking
good pistol shot yep it was it was good
how long was that training for air
marshal uh I think it was like three
months three months and then uh and I
started flying and it became the uh uh
the training officer for the Denver
field office
um because of my Jiu Jitsu background
and uh so that's right this whole time
when did you start training Jiu Jitsu
hardcore I I so I started when I was
five years old I went to Taekwondo
school which and obviously I don't
remember why but somehow I gravitated to
the traditional Jiu Jitsu School in Judo
did that my whole life and when I when I
was on 29 Palms in 1995 I was uh I seen
a sign for jiu jitsu on base and I went
to take it and it ended up being these
two blue belts out of torrent so yeah
and I got and I got it I thought it was
good I got mauled and I'm like I want to
learn that two people you have two
different reactions when you get
experienced Jiu Jitsu they're like I
never want anything to do with that
again or I have to do this and uh and
that was my reaction so 95 I started
Brazilian Jitsu that's where black belts
come from but black belts go dude I want
whatever that person knows I need to
learn about it so that wasn't nice so
you started training pretty regularly
back then and then when you got out
where were you training in Louisiana uh
in Metairie Louisiana there was a guy
named Honey Salas who was at black belt
but we found out he wasn't really a
black belt but he was from Brazil and he
was really good at Jiu Jitsu way better
than us so he put on a black belt and we
he was probably I think he's like a
purple belt and we were like and so that
we'll take it yeah I learned a lot from
him and a guy named Alfredo Ramirez who
was a Japanese Jiu Jitsu black belt but
he was really good at Brazilian Jitsu uh
he went belting Brazilian Jitsu at all
but he was really good he had fun like
the IFC and uh and then we had a guy
named Josh Stewart that fought in the
early day UFC uh so we had some really
uh really good like MMA fighters and and
uh and man we you know back then uh I
know you've been training that long back
then it was it was it was tough and that
tough a tough Matt room yeah yeah and
and even you know back then if you had a
blue belt some someone was a teacher you
could you could run a school as a Blue
Bell 100 like there were schools all
over the place that not all over the
place but there was a lot of schools
that just had a blue belt some blue belt
was teaching and that was that I
remember going to Purple belt seminars
like yeah for sure for sure
uh when you but you and you first
amateur fight in 1999 my first pro fight
in 99 the first amateur fight was in 97.
oh dang okay actually fought Dean Thomas
oh yeah yeah we fought how'd you do
against Dean Thomas I lost it he's a
good freaking guy they told me that it
was his debut he had just came back from
Japan fighting Judo oh dude Monty Cox
was a was a Matchmaker back then and uh
yeah so uh but but yeah me and me and
then became friends over the years but
he's uh and then a 99 return Pro and I
did a couple of those fights where it
was like the the four man brackets yeah
like back then and the rules were so
like different back then you could like
stomp each other in the head I did a few
fights where they were like these like a
little like pads with with elastic under
their fingers not much for gloves not
much for gloves at all yeah so you're
doing these fights you have that officer
involved shooting
um you you end up with the Air Marshals
and then how long are you doing how long
are you actually active working as an
air marshal just under two years like
and that whole time you're reservist I'm
a reservist yeah yeah I'm a reservist
and uh and that's why you know the job
that ended up having in that jsoc task
force I feel super privileged to have
because guys had like a lot more time uh
more qualified than me but I think what
got me I think what got me selected when
I tried out for that task force
eventually was that combination of
experience mainly my undercover
experience
yeah they needed somebody to impersonate
a teenager yeah yeah yeah
I was starting wild man I'm starting to
grow my beard a little bit by then so
so then at what point you get you get um
again you're fighting you had a fight
that was October 20th 2001 like right
after September 11th yeah what fight was
that oh gosh I don't even remember I
think it was like reality uh what was
the what was the atmosphere
the atmosphere must have been freaking
heavy dude you know um
that yeah because the atmosphere of the
country was different right yeah flags
and all over the streets and stuff like
that you know for me like so fighting
back then and you probably remember this
it wasn't as big of a deal as as it is
now like when I remember some of my
first fights like we didn't even like
have a fight card we show up at a place
and they like match you up like okay
you're gonna go that guy looks the same
height as you he's like 30 pounds
heavier like that was kind of that risk
there's still fights like that dude
you go out on the res here in California
you can see some scraps going down like
hey how tall are you what way do you how
tall are you where do you what do you
think you guys want a deal let's make it
happen so but that was probably around
the time that I was starting to do some
you know they were shows you know and uh
but it wasn't as big of a deal I don't
remember like like towards the end of my
fighting but fighting these bigger
fights like Bellator and Strike Force
like you had a camp you know like
obviously like some of your guys here
but
um in those early days like it wasn't
hey you have a fight this weekend I'm
gonna go fighting I mean
yeah I get it from that perspective for
sure nowadays like people have camps and
all that stuff back then it was like
yeah you want to fight this day yeah who
am I gonna fight well I don't know
whoever shows up yeah let's roll
uh and then at some point you have an
opportunity are you so you're in the
Marine Corps reservist and the Marine
Corps has you have an opportunity to go
to a joint Special Operations Command
selection because they need a certain
skill set that kind of ties into the
skill sets that you have you know you
have done undercover work you've been in
law enforcement you uh you have
experience you know obviously with
fighting so it's kind of like a good you
have a good combination for this type of
work that they're looking for and I had
a really good uh connection so if you've
seen the movie Blackhawk Down it's got
him uh the guy that was undercover like
an afo uh guy he was riding a mountain
bike pretending to be a journalist they
got they call the guy hoot in the movie
which after Norm Hooten um but Norm was
actually a squadron like senior listed
guy Rich kachocho Q was that the guy
that was actually fo so he and I were
very good friends and uh and he had kind
of take him in his wing to teach
surveillance detection at the at their
Marshalls as a when I was running the uh
oh so you had that experience as well
yeah so yeah I was I was teaching uh
surveillance detection uh I was teaching
SD SDR uh I was even teaching at the
state department for the State
Department of side like going out
teaching SDA so I had that background as
well in that training and so rich
kachocho and on top of all that you were
in the Marine Corps so you got the
Infantry experience you had the Recon
experience so you're a really good
candidate that's a really good candidate
for someone that's going to be doing
sort of undercover Intel Gathering kind
of clandestine Logistics which is what
which is what they needed that's exactly
right and so I I really didn't even know
what I was trying out for you know I
just know Q I trust him I knew he was
afo at uh at CAG at Delta and uh really
looked up to him and he's like I think
you'd be a really good fit for this I
think you should try out I'll put in a
good word for you and uh so I went and
did this assessment selection and got
and got picked up and uh
and got the opportunity to do you know
what I believe is probably one of the
you know biggest privileges of my life
to serve in that capacity
so how long is that how long is that
school that you go to that's that
assessment selection and training so the
the assessment and selection was like uh
it was like a week long of a you know
interviews and and different skill like
different skill sets proving different
skill sets and then after that the
training uh I probably did I probably
did about eight months of training just
different school it wasn't like one
school it was like different schools a
lot of them are you probably seen this
before a lot of them are like contractor
government contractors that run specific
and some of the schools I went to were
like specifically for like me like me
and one other guy like hey these two
guys are coming to school and so now we
have like six instructors at all former
CAG and they're running a whole school
for us so it's very like High Level
Training uh you know extremely uh
privileged to get that kind of like
mentorship from guys that had done this
job for a long time before and they were
really preparing us they were preparing
us not just for like a lot of times you
go to military school and they're
preparing you for service they were
preparing us for a specific mission and
uh and so that really like when you do
that it really elevates the level of
training you know because you're
training for something specifically they
know what you're going to be doing they
know who you're going to be doing with
they know what your resources they know
what your area of operations is going to
do everything yeah so you're getting
totally detailed training customized for
for you and this at this time you're you
are back to active duty Marine Corps
yeah I went so I went to I went to
active reserves which in the Marine
Corps I'm sure the same maybe you have
active duty you have active reserve so I
went into active reserve contract so it
put me back on active duty fastest way
possible got it and that that's that was
a fast way possible for me but your
paycheck was coming from the Marine
Corps for this for this time period for
this time now there was a point to where
uh I switched to have a direct contract
with my command uh you know at the Json
command that I was at which they do a
lot they do that a lot this particular
command they're just like hey we want
you to stay here we like you uh you're
gonna do the same job but we're gonna
contract you directly and that's that's
how I ended up staying at the unit that
was at got it
um
so 2003 you you do your first deployment
here to Afghanistan
um I'm actually gonna go to the book
here
this is the book once again and look
this we're going to read a small portion
of this book today there's all kinds of
details in here that I'm not going to go
into there's all kind of stories that
I'm not going to read because well get
the book and and you can read it but
um this is one part I think ties this in
pretty good you see I was conducting
logistical support operations for my
assaulter teams tasks with capturing or
killing the highest value targets of
Taliban leaders in the Afghanistan
region getting my guys out safely and
everything else in between Aziz was my
interpreter from start to finish he had
been teaching English in that apartment
building when my teammate Andy recruited
him to our task force Aziz spoke English
extremely well and as crazy as it sounds
teaching English under Taliban rule was
a risky way to make a living Aziz was 25
years old married and knew his country
inside and out he was also street smart
and capable a necessity for an
interpreter in our task forces
assignments
as with all the Afghans hired as
interpreters we brought Aziz in at entry
level to allow him to allow us time to
see him at work and discern how much we
could trust him interpreters job
description varied depending on the
units which they were attached an
interpreter assigned to an
administrative unit for example would be
asked only to interpret but in an
infantry unit an interpreter would also
fight alongside our troops by signing up
for Special Operations Aziz knew he was
taking on a dangerous assignment but
that fit his personality courageous and
passionate of the local Nationals
working with us Aziz quickly worked his
way into becoming our most capable and
trusted although Aziz came to us with no
former military background his father
had been part of the Afghan Army in the
late 1980s that the or sorry in the
1980s that the Soviet Union held build
up
in support of its fight against
Insurgent groups Aziz had grown up
around fighting from childhood and
understood the military mindset we
fast-tracked aziz's trainings
our command's job was to hunt down the
Most Wanted bad guys on the battlefield
and we made sure Aziz could shoot
communicate as needed and facilitate
everything necessary at times I worked
along alongside other task force team
members but mostly I was alone except
for having Aziz with me Aziz and I
traveled in what into what we called
non-conventional or non-permissive areas
where combat support and support forces
were not operating in addition to
working in Afghanistan we worked in the
federally administered tribal area that
blurred the border between Afghanistan
and Pakistan
our purpose was to go into these areas
to establish a presence and build soft
missions support for kinetic action
contingencies and escape and by the way
it's funny uh I'm looking at the book
right now there's a bunch of stuff that
when you sent this book to the Pentagon
they redacted a bunch of a bunch of
things and you know with my background I
I know it's redacted I'm trying to read
it in a way that we don't don't have to
keep saying redacted but um there's a
bunch of stuff in here that they've
blacked out and that it's fine it
doesn't it doesn't impact understanding
of what's going on
but you just gave sort of the background
of what you guys were doing you know
going in there you've got you know
assault teams or tactical teams that are
gonna go and do missions hit targets
well there's
those guys need
certain support and that's what you guys
were doing
um I mean a lot of people look you know
you look at like how does how does a you
know assault Force get on get to a
Target in a non-permissive area and get
off Target safely like what is no
support like and uh usually you know
people don't realize is there's guys
that go there before them and set it all
up and in all the contingencies right
you think of safe house like what goes
in a safe house you know
ammo guns blood a safe rum money clothes
vehicles with permits on this vehicle
it's about to get through certain
checkpoints and no no it know which know
what uh those checkpoints can be looking
for so those vehicles have to have all
those things like somebody goes ahead
figures all that out and puts it all in
place that way when you know scow time
everything's done flawlessly yeah yeah
it's like when you when you go and watch
like a documentary about a rock and roll
band sure right the rock and roll band
they show up in Chicago
bro there's there's a hotel room for
them their drinks are where they want
them there's like security set
everything's ready all they do is got to
do is get there get on stage and rock
and roll right yeah but all the other
stuff like even the flights coming in
the people picked them up at the airport
all that stuff is taken care of there's
you know depending on what who the rock
band is maybe there's some uh substances
there that they request that had to be
acquired there's all this stuff going on
it has to be done in a clandestine way
it sounds like a lot it sounds like team
like Team guys they get no they get no
freaking uh they get no uh Glory right
right those it's like even not not even
the Roadies not even the Roadies we're
not talking we're talking before the
Roadies show up right so all those
Logistics have to take place before the
band can rock and roll and it's hard to
do that in a non-permissive in a combat
environment and uh that's kind of kind
of what you have going on with your job
and it takes an incredible amount of
effort to make that happen yeah one of
the things you said earlier is you know
a lot of guys in in Special Operations
Community like that sounds like super
sexy and everybody wouldn't do that but
a lot of guys Special Operations
Community do not want to do that job
yeah when they learn about it and uh and
then there's certain guys that like that
like are built to do it and love doing
that thing for me that was like I didn't
even know this job existed and then once
I learned I'm like this is right up by
alley this is exactly like what I'm
supposed to be doing and I enjoyed it
and I liked it yeah no it's uh it's like
I said I'm not suited for that job I
mean even just I mean look I was doing
work with the with the oga one time and
the guy's like dude you you have no you
have no you have no reason to be here
like you you stand out as a special
operations guy from any angle like yeah
he's like you could not get this and you
said you could not get the special
operations tank off you if you tried and
I was like yeah Roger that
um so that's the way it is and it's
funny too it's not like I you know not
like I ever thought about that that's
just my whole life I just grew up you
know that in the teams like you're gonna
end up being that way and I guess I I
guess I ended up being that one a lot so
anyways we had we had a team guy that
was like put in with us one time uh I'll
say his name off off there if you want
to do later but I don't see it here but
he was that way they tried to put him in
with us because he had this like
specific skill set for this one like
like a feasibility study we're doing for
a future operation and he was like check
like Raj I'm like I'm like dude like
you're gonna get his freaking skinned
alive like yeah all day long he was just
you know he just looked at two and uh
and you probably know him but I was so
we end up having him like really just
train me up and uh not come out like he
just really spun me up on something that
I had no experience doing but he really
he really trained me out I'm not going
undercover anywhere it's basically what
I'm getting at
um we we were one time uh we were in
July uh jalalabad
it was me and Aziz in uh and and Dave
Limon and the three of us are in this in
this where like Warehouse we had set it
up we had like vehicle stage and the
sort of Team guys so so Team guys that
came there they went to
free fall in I don't think they really
need to free fall but they wanted it for
that free fall jump in Afghanistan so so
they they actually did a we were
supposed to I wanted an internet too so
we thought we'd get to going and we
ended up not getting it going on it but
they jumped in and uh and then patrolled
over to where we're at and and there's
medicine in his warehouse and they get
in there and they're like coming in and
they like you know got their quads on
and they're like you know do it doing a
you know the perimeter like doing their
their sales like stop look listen smell
they're like doing all this and you know
we're just like hey what's up guys like
coming out with our tea like like you
guys are freaking stupid they're like I
guess you're nuts like we live here
uh right on you go on to say here I was
assigned well over 100 Missions uh no
one was beside me or more instrumental
in this text of in the success of these
message missions as much as Aziz this is
skills expertise knowledge and
connections made our work successful
Aziz and I continuously operated in
environments dangerous to us not only
because we were embedded in Afghanistan
but by the nature of our assignments
because we were in areas where our
Command wanted to Target operating
Taliban we went by ourselves to where
the Taliban were without Military
Support immediately available to us
so
that's what you're doing
um and and again some people are gonna
have to use your imaginations a little
bit because obviously a lot of what
you're doing was was and still is
classified but that's that's the type of
missions that you're doing you're in
areas where you're not going to get
support your your best methodology for
survival is being able to blend in and
and keep that stuff uh as tight as you
possibly can so you you're going you're
you're doing these missions how often
are you going on deployment how how long
are you coming home for what are they
these are shorter deployments shorter
diplomas yeah I think a lot a lot of
people like eight deployments In
fairness my diplomats were like like
four months long I think the longest one
was six and uh and then I come but I
come home for like three months I'll be
back out again sometimes even 60 days
I'd be home just enough to go to some
and it's not really like going home and
relaxing I'm going home and going to
school going to schools getting trained
up for the next we do it every every
time out we do a we do a pre-deployment
uh cologne that was called loan operator
course we go to Las Vegas got MJ it's
called jtm Jim Jim Mitchell training or
JMT gym Mitchell training he's a former
PJ guy he has a bunch of cat guys on his
staff they would do all the
pre-deployment stuff and so I get so
yeah there's always training between any
back out again how's your wife like all
this uh actually at the time
uh
our kids are small so she's just like so
busy and she's uh I say that's not
insulting to her at all it's actually
probably was a blessing for us she was
like extremely naive to what I was doing
and she didn't care like I could have
been out there as a Halliburton cook
yeah like and she didn't know the
difference or care like like you're
going you're going to work a lot like my
wife yeah she's just like yeah going to
work would you give me home I'm pretty
sure I'll be home in six months okay bye
yeah yeah are you gonna pack your lunch
like actually I mean if I went home and
said I want to be a bank robber tomorrow
she'd ask if I want a lunch but you know
like she just said that's none of that
matters to her she's never been
impressed by the Recon Banger all this
thing she just did not faced by it at
all so she was just really she's a mom
and she's a housewife and that's what
she loves to do and that's not you know
that's just who she is and so she just
really thrived and just taking care of
her kids and making sure she always felt
like her part was to make sure that Iowa
didn't have a heavy burden of what was
going on back home that's also very
similar to my wife my wife was like she
got you know she's taking care of the
home front so I could go and do my job
in the meantime you're also coming
you're still fighting
you know I was like looking at your
record
um on shirt dog or whatever one of those
and you you 2004 February 7th you had a
fight a pro fight you won
um April 19th you had a pro fight you
won
November 16th you had a pro fight you
won this is like you're an active those
are normal those are normal intervals
for a professional fighter in this day
and age I was I was fighting I was
fighting guys that were training full
time too while I was doing so like I'd
be over I always kind of jump rope with
me in bands because you can't go out
jogging in uh yeah in jalalabad yeah so
I'd always had a jump rope I always had
bands with me everywhere I went uh and
and uh and I ran into some I had this
guy I ended up hiring him he was a
wrestler from Afghanistan and we carry
mats with us and wrestle with him and he
was actually pretty good yeah and uh and
so I was teaching him Jiu Jitsu he was a
really good wrestler and I trained with
him out there but I mean I come back and
and as part of
you'll probably relate to this it was
part of my
you could get really out of shape really
quick in this in this job because I'm
not I'm not I'm not they don't have a
gym I don't have you know go I'm not on
base I'm going out and I'm like three
months out in the mountains and so you
get really out of shape really fast so
when I come home like I would crush
myself like I have to get myself back in
and so putting a fight on the calendar
for me was like a mental like Target to
push myself and I've always kind of been
that way I always want something on the
calendar because I'm I'm like when you
talk about discipline a lot like I'm I'm
probably the the hardest working lazy
person I know like because like I'll
finish a fight and the next morning I'm
like I'm too lazy to take vitamins like
so like having it
so having like a something on the
calendar always pushes me to uh to be
prepared I never I never like doing
something and not prepared for so if I
have that date in the calendar so it's
doing these fights or something that
would like force me back into I come
home and like can I compete a jiu jitsu
tournament MMA fight like can I compete
while I'm home and that would push push
me to get back in shape now it seemed
like there's a chunk of time a few years
where you know you you didn't fight you
were probably just absorbed in work
that's what my assumption is you're just
working going on appointment and you you
don't feel like you're
um ready to fight yeah and and these
deployments just continue
um that being said
2009 you know January 31st you fight
um you win
April 17th 2009 you fight you win
November 7th 2009 you fight you win you
got a freaking good record at this point
like you were undefeated actually yeah
that's that's freaking outstanding sure
dog's missing like like five fights too
oh are they yeah I think your record
ended up being like 13. sure dog has 13
it makes martial arts.com has 18 and two
okay yeah well there you go uh a bunch
of fights you're you're living this life
um and it sounds cool when we're talking
about it right now but
it started to take its toll yeah and I'm
gonna go to the book here for a chunk
you say this during my eighth and last
deployment I was conducting a
feasibility study for an operation
targeting a high level Taliban leader in
the mountains Aziz flew in to help while
we were there we got caught up in the
middle of a tribal rivalry we were
inside a building when we heard shooting
break out from both sides of the street
I looked out to see cars blocking the
road wagons flipped over and tires on
fire for Hasty covers the tribal members
fired each other
it was rather typical it was a rather
typical day for such a hostile area but
Aziz and I wanted no part of the action
we scrambled through the back of the
building and escaped the area we
completed the study and one of our
special operations teams came in and
killed the Taliban leader
I was called back to the Persian Gulf to
meet with our leadership and they
informed me the Taliban had captured and
killed a group of 10 Afghan team members
who had worked for me
this was a special group to me I'd eaten
in their homes with their families and
played with their kids these guys knew
my location and possessed the ability to
compromise me the Taliban held them for
a week and then hanged them except for
two who flipped to the Taliban side and
then turned the others over causing
their deaths
I loved these men they were my friends I
would have died for them and they would
have died for me in fact I believe they
did die for me
despite being compromised I returned and
continued to on with our operation
because I believed its importance was
worth the personal risk
a few days after arrive I arrived I was
abducted by Taliban sympathizers
at 5 a.m I heard a knock on the door and
through the window I could see Jack a
guy who had spent time with in his home
and and an older man Jack claimed to be
Canadian but he was clearly Pakistani
both were dressed in suits and ties when
I opened the door two more guys came out
of hiding the four men forced me out of
my doorway and into the back of a car
they drove me to the hills outside of
town I thought for certain they were
going to kill me but I was going to put
up a hell of a fight when the first gun
came out the heavily the men heavily
interrogated me for an hour or two but I
held up and for some reason they chose
to release me I attempted one more
operation after that but my mind was not
in a good place I was experiencing
severe physiological reactions panic
attacks and mental disassociation
sometimes feeling as if I had awakened
from a dream state
that's sketchy
yeah um I know they some of that was
redacted and uh and I changed the
wording but you know it won't say which
one but it was a foreign intelligence
agency that that uh grabbed me and I
knew who I knew it was when they grabbed
me and uh
you know you know what's fear sets in
you if you don't deal with it it becomes
just erodes you and uh I remember flying
back in after we learned this our guys
were killed and and making a decision
because it was like hey you guys still
in
um I was like in disease too as we were
like yeah we have to we've been putting
three years in the end of this in this
operation
and uh and uh that flight over I
remember I landed in Beijing and on that
later in Beijing was the first time I
ever had a panic attack in my life I
didn't know what it was I thought they
sprayed like for the bird flu uh thing
and I was like man like I had a relative
reaction I tried to get off the plane it
would let me off the plane and I was
having a panic attack and then and then
when I landed uh in the country I went
to that when I landed there I was I was
in bad shape and I was by myself and so
I started dealing with these panic
attacks and I knew that that
intelligence agency was out to get me
and I pushed you know I think it was
just too much to push forward uh through
and uh and then I don't know if I
mention it there but in another spot we
had a house in Afghanistan they drove a
b-bid a vehicle bomb into our house
leveled our house
um it was it was it was bad time and uh
that wasn't I was in bad shape
say this here fast forward a little bit
and again there's a lot of details in
here that I'm skipping over but that's
why people get the book you say the
execution of our Afghan teammates the
interrogation and the attempt to kill me
and my teammates shook me up pretty good
my panic attacks and physiological
symptoms were progressing rapidly or
sorry yeah physiological symptoms were
progressing rapidly In a Moment of
clarity I concluded my declining mental
condition had placed me and others in
danger I needed medical help I
communicated to my leadership over an
open phone line that I wasn't feeling
well and instead of visiting a local
doctor I needed to see one in the Gulf
that was a signal that something serious
was wrong with me I booked a round trip
flight to avoid raising suspicions and
left behind all my personal belongings
other than what I stuffed into an
overnight backpack at the airport
leaving I was paranoid about everyone
around me I noticed more police inside
the airport than normal I believe they
were looking for me I passed through
customs with the feeling that I was
rolling the dice for my life and game of
roulette only to make it through and
then learn my flight was delayed I was
convinced they were holding up the
flight until they caught me I remember
staring at the hands on the clock and
feeling like time was frozen finally we
were called to board the plane to this
day I can't clearly I can clearly
remember every moment of going through
the gate and jetway to walk onto the
plane
I don't know if I ever felt more
relieved than when the wheels lifted
from the runway and we cleared the
mountains my leadership held me in the
Gulf for four days I guess to ensure no
one was following me they prohibited me
from calling anyone but I called my
grandmother granny who was like a mother
to me my panic attacks had convinced me
I was dying and I wanted to tell her
goodbye then I called my wife Kathy for
the first time since we met she heard
weakness and fear in my voice Kathy
arranged to fly there to be with me but
my command sent some of our team members
to our home and shut down her plans of
coming over for her safety and to
prevent further compromise I spent four
days in the Persian Gulf alone I
ventured out to a pharmacy and purchased
Valium to calm me down and get me
through the flight to the states even at
home I wasn't mentally right
I was non-stop anxious my hands and arms
would go numb then my face my throat
would feel like it was swelling shut and
I struggled to breathe I would feel like
I had a thousand pound weight on my
chest
I met with a psychologist and was
diagnosed with severe chronic
post-traumatic stress disorder
subsequently I was removed from the task
force along with the operations I was
participating in by that point in my
career I had Direct contract with my
command meaning I was no longer on
active duty I essentially was out of a
job at home for good
I brought all the anxiety guilt
frustration anger and shame home with me
being pulled out of the game without
finishing the business of stopping the
Taliban and making Afghanistan safer
which I had come to dedicate my life to
made things worse nobody understood me I
believed everyone was against me
and the toxic mix of thoughts and fears
raging inside me was their fault not
mine I closed myself off to others all I
knew to do was what I had trained to do
fight but now I was fighting for myself
and by myself and I was losing
I trained in martial arts since age five
and in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu since age 19
I'd also competed as an amateur and
professional mixed martial arts fighter
with an unbeaten record Kathy suggests
we open a jiu jitsu school and I went
full bore into training and running the
school
I also returned to fighting
professionally in MMA within three years
our school grew to two locations and a
thousand students and I still had not
lost a fight had won a World title and
climbed to number six in the world
rankings in the flyweight division
I look like I was winning at everything
but my life was a complete failure
Kathy and I separated and filed for
divorce I convinced myself the best
thing I could do for our three children
was commit suicide
in September 2010 while pressing a
pistol to my head I heard someone
outside my apartment door I hid the gun
when I opened the door Kathy was
standing there we engaged in a heated
argument that led her to ask me a
life-altering question Chad how can you
do all the things you've done in the
military Afghanistan be willing to die
for your buddies trained so hard for
your MMA fights and show such discipline
to cut weight for competitions but when
it comes to your family
you quit
there's no more soul-cutting word to me
than being called the quitter but she
was absolutely correct I had found
professional success but when it came to
the most important things like being a
husband or father and having the will to
get well
I had quit
yeah
yeah it was a very
looking back it's uh it was
that that spiral happened like
like so quickly I mean it was three
years that spiral was three years but it
was it was it would just it happened so
quickly and it was so out of control and
I just kept trying to find ways to get
control of my life and man I just
couldn't
um and I was I think more than anything
yet like the panic attacks and the level
of panic attacks were like debilitating
like I felt like literally I expressed
that description I felt like I was gonna
die
but on top of all that whatever was
worse for me as I was embarrassed I was
I was just that that's the simplest word
I could give for it I was just
embarrassed because so what were you
embarrassed about
because you know you I worked my whole
life to get
you know my whole like we talked about
my story like everything at work to get
to a place like that that I didn't even
feel like I was qualified to be at
because so many people had so much more
military experience than me about to be
at a unit like that to be on that
mission and I was like when I was doing
a cross-border stuff like I was given
like the keys to the kingdom to do this
operation uh like so I felt so
privileged to be there and then I wasn't
trusted with all this and then I felt
like I failed you know I felt like I
failed that and I felt like I was like
like if I played NFL you know made it
little league all the D1 college and
then an NFL and the Super Bowl and then
you you fumbled the ball that's what I I
felt like I did I was entrusted with
this and I failed and I was embarrassed
and you know you've been in that
environment some people kind of alluded
to that and uh you know there's people
that I that I trusted and looked up to
and would have would have died for them
and they were like you know looked at me
that way uh and and even said things
to you know hey man you like let us down
like you know you were you were fine
last month you were fine last month like
and uh man it was things like
you you don't you don't like brush those
things off when your people you respect
and uh and it hurt and I was just like
embarrassed and uh and so I just wanted
to hide from it like like I talk like
right now everything about my life's
like military you know my Instagram but
in that time when I came back I didn't
want any I didn't want to mention
anything about the military to anyone
that three years was like Jiu Jitsu
people ask me about the military I just
like pretty much ignore him I didn't
want to talk about what years was this
uh 2000 I came home in April of 07.
and uh so from April 07 to
pretty much 2010. where was your juicy
Scrolls in The Woodlands Texas oh okay
so if you uh if you follow a guy named
Alex Morano he's a UFC fighter right now
he's uh he was one of my students back
then he runs the same school now what's
the name of the school no now it's
Gracie about how the woodlands got it so
and that school's still there that
school's still there yeah that's a it's
a pretty thriving school they got they
just put out put out the last Ultimate
Fighter Ricky tarcios came out he was he
was a kid in my school back then so he
just they but they put out some good
guys that's all that's awesome it's just
so bizarre right like to read this and
you got your school I mean a thousand
students at a jiu jitsu school or even
two Jiu Jitsu schools but that means
you're financially doing I was doing
well totally comfortable I mean that's a
great job you're impacting people you're
around people all the time right like so
it's not like you're isolated from an
external perspective right you've got
students you got other instructors but
you know what I was isolated from was
accountability I assist thematically uh
pushed everybody out of my life that
would say anything hard to me and and I
had made my life to where everybody just
lifted me up and no one told me the
things I needed to hear people just told
me what I wanted to hear I I did that
like uh you know and I was I felt like I
was probably I was pretty pretty good at
that like I could just manipulate
relationships to to have people around
me that just like Lifted Me Up and
enabled me and no fault to any of them I
was I was I was doing that and and like
you said the Jiu Jitsu school like the
success of it we opened the doors like I
came home in April by by summer like I'm
like I'm gonna be out of money like I
need to figure out how to take care of
my family so I like just
got back and and just started crying to
make this work and opened the doors with
like 180 students which you know so then
day one you were making I'm making good
money yeah I was able to take care of my
family right away so coming out so
anybody on the outside looking at this
would have thought
you know I was being successful but I
mean I was still dealing with panic like
debilitating panic attacks I was a
tyrant to my family like uh I'm not a
I'm like a pretty like like kind person
like especially a like love my love my
family uh tremendously and but at that
time I was like yelling at my wife like
a Marine Corps drill instructor punching
holes in the walls slamming doors
breaking things uh it was one time I
came home like from my little girl's
birthday and she's having a birthday
party and she didn't like the icing on
her cake like something something super
simple and I picked up my little girl's
cake and threw it against the wall and
destroyed my little girl's birthday in
him I remember like what kind of person
what kind of dad behaves that way and I
was just so out of control that I just
started isolating myself more because I
I just felt like it was a behavior and I
couldn't get get hold of so really this
manifested all this bad behavior from
you manifested in your wife filing for
divorce yeah because I'm done with this
[__] well it really I think she was in
she was she was trying so hard like uh
she's like a really strong one of Faith
she was like she was like trying so hard
and uh but our marriage just kind of me
isolated myself a marriage just like
drifted apart so I'd sleep in a friend's
house at the gym I had like a place to
sleep at the gym I would uh sleep my
kids room my wife and I talk now a lot
about it like the loneliest place we
save or ever been is not me to win a
deployment but in our own beds like our
backs turn to each other and just like a
dead marriage and so we were just like
really separating our own home staying
together for the kids and you know
there's a lot of girls around jiu jitsus
and Jiu Jitsu gems and so it didn't take
long for me to end up in relationships
with other women so I ended up in a
full-blown Affair and didn't really even
care like that was so like callous and I
had like so little empathy that I didn't
even care so when my wife found out the
solution was
let's just get divorced uh this isn't
working anyway and so we filed for
divorce moved into two separate
Apartments signed 12-month leases so
we're pretty committed you know sold our
home that we worked so hard to buy and
uh and uh my wife and I two really
different reactions uh she went to a
church
um she changed churches she went to
church to be around people that she
thought would be like really supportive
like a like a good positive group not
people that would be like oh your
husband's a you know jerk anyway like it
was people that would like give her good
support and uh and she said you know she
would go in there not just on Sundays
but like every like a couple of days a
week and just pray for me and you know
she's people would wonder you know what
could a woman pray for you and when
you'd be in the behaving that way and
she said she would pray like God let me
see Chad the way you see Chad let me
love Chad the way you love Chad let me
forgive Chad the way you forgive Chad
like that's what she was like doing this
for me while I'm like running around
with women and I'm like my reaction was
I got this apartment bachelor pad set up
in like two days no family pictures
outside I had all my favorite pictures
it's kind of growth asked for me to say
but at all my family pictures on a shelf
in my closet so like when girls come
over that they wouldn't see that stuff
and and uh it's like totally being a
degenerate I signed up for a fight on
Strikeforce uh it was like one of the
last big Strike Force cards the UFC had
on the strike force at that time and uh
and so I just like
dove into that I'm like I can stay busy
I don't have to deal with this woman
anymore and I fought a kid named my
birthday de Leon and we were like it was
like a highly touted fight because he
was like we're both in the area and he
was like I forget what his professional
record was but he was like really known
for amateur because he went like 18-0 as
an amateur and uh he's like a really
good Striker and they were talking smack
about me being a ground guy had
submitted all my opponents but I
wouldn't strike so Eagle got the best of
me I was feeling pretty good in my
boxing I stood in the middle of that
cage with him and we it was like my
Rocky fight like back and forth I had
submitted everyone before but now I go
to descended and every round like he
punched me and knocked me down and I
kicked him in the face and knocked him
down even knocked his mouthpiece out
like a good good kick to the face it was
like a pretty good fight and at the end
I remember they're like they're like
going to announce a decision and I'm
like oh my gosh like what happened I
don't remember what happened and my
corner is like this could be close man
and I'm like and they had called the one
judge calls for her pill the other's for
me and I'm like oh my gosh I just lost
my first fight and then the third judge
culture me my hands raised you know 10
000 people screaming and I remember like
having this moment you know you've been
in that cage like people were screaming
and it's like loud and like deafening
but like everything got quiet and I
remember thinking like man all these
people here Kathy's not here and I just
fought so hard for this stupid like
which I loved Jujitsu right but but it's
in context right that's so far so hard
for the stupid win on my record but
Meanwhile my family's like devastated
and that's when I went home that night
with my head held I just went me and Tim
Kennedy because he fought in that card
we had after bite party Ranger up
through it for us at uh at Buffalo Wild
Wings a stopped in checked in went home
to my apartment and I was laying in bed
just realizing like man I'm like what do
I have like my life like everything that
I'm good at is over
my life's like I don't have any purpose
moving forward my family is the only
thing I have and I destroyed them and
and a stall came over me like maybe my
family would be sad without me but
they'd be better off and you know that
you know you know that same hopeless
life finds a home in the hearts of
20-something veterans every single day
and I didn't want to take my life to
escape my situation I thought it was the
betterment for the betterment of my
family and and uh and I really had
believed that
um and I made a decision to do that
so you made the decision you're going to
kill yourself yeah yeah and that night
after you freaking won Strike Force yeah
yeah I was laying in my bed that night
that's when I decided and I wasn't gonna
tell anybody I didn't want anyone to
intervene uh the one thing that would I
saw it sit in that closet I put my I
literally put my family pictures on the
floor around me and like and I had that
like Glock 22 pistol and when I put the
gun to my head I would have this vision
of like how it play out like somebody's
gonna find you somebody could get a
gunshot you're not gonna show up
somewhere it's an apartment you can
start smelling like someone's someone's
gonna find you and uh the only other
person had a key to my apartment at a
time was my oldest son Hunter who's 13
at the time so you know I heard a
statistic that one in three children
from a parent that commit suicide or do
it as well and uh and so that thought
would come to my mind I'm like man my
son's gonna find me so that was enough
to pump the brakes but I'd be in such a
dark place I'd be back at it uh like I
was convinced that that was the right
thing to do I convinced myself of that
and then that's when Kathy I came how
long were you in that mindset for about
two weeks and I'd snap out of it but I
was just like this looming it was almost
like this feeling like
like I'm driving like there's a pole I
could just turn my wheel or you know I'm
standing right edge of your building
like I just I just have to jump like
have a bottle of pills next to me like I
just have to then it's done like I just
had this like it was just like almost
like this
like a almost like a spiritual like
influence like just like and uh you know
I'm not saying that's what it was but it
was just like it was like something just
looming that was just like there for
like and I had thought about it a lot
before but in that two weeks I was like
committed to do it and uh and uh but I
just could not get past that
how to how to get past not leaving that
for my kids and uh and and then that's
when Kathy came to my apartment I was
literally uh I had that pistol and she
knocked on the door I wasn't gonna
answer it because I didn't know who it
was but when I heard her voice uh this
is my apartment my closet she would
never came in there but I panicked and I
hid that gun in her blanket which was
probably because of Shame and I went to
the door and I was so it sounds Twisted
to say but I was so mad that she was
there interrupting me killing myself
that I just started screaming at her and
she's not a very calm arguer but but in
that moment she was like she was like
totally calm and she asked me that
question you know how could you do all
the stuff she like laid out all this
stuff and weight cutting was always a
big thing to her because she's like the
discipline like I could like having I
love Doritos like I don't eat them now
but but like just a lick I wouldn't even
lick the nacho cheese off in a house by
myself like that kind of discipline
she's like how could you do all of that
because she had to see all that you know
and how could you do all of that but
when it comes to your family you'll quit
what was it that brought her over that
specific night did she like how does she
explain that what she she had talked to
me that morning I don't recall the
conversation but she had a intuition
that I was going to hurt myself
and she had she just she just said she
just knew uh something was wrong
something was off and she felt like I
was gonna hurt myself
and uh I didn't say anything to allude
to that but she just had that that
women's intuition
you say this in the book Kathy was
attending church and praying for me my
recovery and our family I asked if she
could find a man at her church to
counsel me and provide accountability
that led to Steve Toth entering my life
and leading me to become a Christian
before them before then I would say I
was a Christian I wore military dog tag
that claimed I was one but for the first
time in my life I surrendered my life to
Jesus after my recovery I created a
Ministry called The Mighty Oaks
Foundation to help combat veterans and
those from the military communities
suffering from PTSD and life issues to
move Beyond life's hardships and into
the life God created us all to live
over 20 veterans a day were committing
suicide and I felt compelled to tell
every struggling veteran veteran I could
the lesson I had learned during my
journey in life just like in combat we
aren't meant to fight alone with Mighty
Oaks
they wouldn't have to
so that's when you started the The
Mighty Oaks Foundation yeah you know I
tried everything I had been on a
medication I've been through all the
counseling at the VA and civilian
counseling programs and
financial success like you said at Jiu
Jitsu professional success at the
accolades like some of those things are
good some of those things are bad but
none of those things really changed my
situation and and uh you know with Steve
you know I had literally like wrote a
five paragraph order up order of how I
was gonna fix my life I met him with him
at Starbucks I wanted him to show it to
my wife so like proudly and smugly slid
over to him and he didn't even look at
it and he led it back over to me and
told me I was going to fail I remember
being like super offended but then he
tapped in a paper and he said if this
plan doesn't have anything to do with
your relationship with Gotham I'm not
gonna waste your time I'm not gonna let
you waste mine and like I said I tried
everything and so it was the one thing
that I had never really been intentional
about and so I made a decision to
surrender my life to Christ become a
Christian but beyond that Steve mentored
me your entire year and what would be
called discipleship you know biblical
living and teaching me how to how to
make better choices and that's what I
really discovered like
as bad as like some things I've been in
my life like you know like the loss of
friends and you know the pain that comes
with that and my childhood and all these
bad things that happened to me as bad as
those things were those things didn't
leave me to be in a closet I'm a pistol
man when it led me there were the
choices that I made in response to those
things and so I had really inventory in
my life through this mentorship that
Steve was giving me like the reason I
was going on the stretch actually I was
going was I was just making bad choices
and so as Steve started mentoring me in
his biblical living I still had anxiety
I still had depression I still dealt
with anger and frustration but now I had
better a blueprint for making better
choices and I was super intentional
about that I'm kind of that way if I'm
all in on something I'm going to be all
in so it's very intentional very
disciplined about it and uh and by being
intentional about it I started seeing
Restoration in my own Brokenness and my
own anxiety depression I started feeling
like finding healing in it and I started
finding Restoration in my family my
family now we've been married 27 years
and
you know three amazing kids they're all
married two of them went to Bible
College two of them went to Marine Corps
I got two granddaughters one in the way
like we have this amazing family and I
found Hope again and ultimately I found
purpose uh through that and that purpose
manifested in like a real deep burden I
believe God put him a heart to share
that lesson with others and that
manifested in the founding of Mighty
Oaks Foundation you know and that was 12
years ago and over the last 12 years
I've spoken to a half man active duty
troops have run that we run a recovery
program we do about five to six million
dollars a year in programming free for
active duty veterans First Responders or
spouses at five ranchers we have around
the country uh do this recovery we're
doing like 35 camps a year and about a
thousand people for a year we put
through it it's a week-long camp and
then we'd have a program with policy to
fight and navigate for a veterans uh
faith-based veterans care in DC I was on
the chair I was the chairman of the
White House's faith-based Coalition in
2018 and 19. and then we have our
international program we go around the
world to their Allied partners and give
those same principles at my docs that
would help U.S service members we help
people and our partners around the world
and I've been to Ukraine like 10 times
since February helping the Ukrainian
troops out there
so like that's kind of what this all
manifested into it's just paying it
forward honestly that's all it is for me
Mighty Oaks is just an opportunity to
pay for what you know the second chance
that Kathy gave me the second chance
that God gave me the mentorship that
Steve gave me it's just it's been paid
forward and we we don't just help
veterans we teach them to do the same
and really Empower them to be able to do
the same for others and that's why it's
become like it's grown so fast because
you know the discipleship process is
just replicating replicating and not
just helping people but equipping them
to be part of the solution yeah I know
uh we were talking about our mutual
friend Matt who is a seal who he's on
the board I guess of yeah but he was he
was early on he was even more engaged
and involved with Mighty Oaks and he was
the guy that I would call if someone
reached out to me that was really having
issues
uh and I remember one time you know we
were talking and and like just to
the and I don't want to say the
specifics because I don't know I don't
want to break any privacy uh
of anyone but a guy had checked in who
was like severely wounded from
self-inflicted
um
from a self-inflicted situation and you
know he was able to take this guy who
had tried very hard to kill himself and
we're able to get this guy kind of back
on track and that to me was a real
Testament to what you guys are doing
um and you know we already talked about
Lou like my buddy Lou Who has a team
three with just an awesome guy and I
know he had some significant struggles
and you know just to see his life turn
around it's just awesome to see
um so yeah the the things that you guys
are doing with Mighty Oaks is is just
outstanding how long was it before your
wife and you got back together like when
did you guys get back in this under the
same roof yeah so so I'm like yeah I'm
pretty radical personality so so I'm
like when they made this decision I'm
like hey I'll like you don't have to
trust me like I'm gonna I'm gonna fix
this the same character that work ethic
the discipline you're talking about like
I'm gonna fix this like I'll cause the
problems I'm gonna fix this so I'll I'll
sleep on your back porch but uh but I'm
coming home and uh not I mean I had an
apartment she had an apartment but I'm
going to where you are and uh and she's
like you're not going back and I'm like
I'll sleep outside like I'm I caused the
damage to do this she didn't make me
sleep outside but she let me on the
couch and and uh eventually I worked my
way back in our bedroom but uh but uh it
was it was probably a year of really
like
um
deliberate like work to put up put my
marriage back together uh that that
first phase and then and then it
probably took like five or six years to
really heal from from what I've done but
but that that first year was like me
making a decision
because I'm pretty prideful like so when
I think like hey things are fixed now
like
like we should they need to put this
behind us that's kind of my mentality I
think most men's mentality but for me it
was like realizing like I heard her like
she's gonna get me entitled to
being hurt lashing out throwing things
back in my face like I had to make the
decision I was gonna allow that to
happen because otherwise we would have
never been able to get through it
because there was I would go I'd come
home sometimes she was happy I was home
sometimes she was like you disgust me
like I don't want you in the same house
as me like she was hurt and I heard her
I did you know betrayed her in a worse
way a husband could portray a wife so I
had to I had to really work through that
and luckily that mentorship with Steve
was like
man like why she's throwing stuff in my
face again this you want to sabotage us
and he's like man like did you not
betray her did you not break her trust
did you not like uh you know does she
not have a reason to not trust you like
all those things were like yeah I gotta
so I'm gonna have to be the one that
just bites the bullet on this and and
let her hurt and let her bent let her uh
you know throw things back in my face
until we so she gets that out of her
system and and earn that trust back so
that's what I did
uh by the way you got another book
called fight for us which I didn't read
the whole thing normally I didn't
realize about this book until a little
late but uh but there's a bunch of
really good sections in there so check
that book out as well
um and that's basically about well it
says win back the marriage God intends
for you so this is about you know
relationships but you've also got a
bunch of cool stories in there actually
you cover your time in the police forces
really good book as well meantime well
you got this going on 2011 April 16th
you you lose your I think this is your
first fight uh that you lose in Bellator
fought Bellator champ Zach makovsky was
a champ at the time and uh so you know
can't wait right in the Bellator
fighting the champ uh no one want to
fight Zach at that time and I was like
heck yeah you know let's go let's go
yeah man he's he's awesome guy at the
time I thought he was one of the best
fighters in the world and that
opportunity to compete you know you
always if you're a real fighter like you
want to compete against the very best
and uh and I had the chance to you yeah
uh you fought again July 22nd you lost
in a guillotine first round quick what
happened bro I know man you know that
one did you listen when I came Kennedy
on the podcast
I like people pointed out to me I was
I'd be like bro you lost that was so
hurt that he lost because I'd be rooting
for Tim so hard like when he was
fighting so I didn't lose I'd be like
bro what happened Brad what happened you
know it was at makovsky it was like
but people was like that's your first
loss like how'd that hurt I'm like man I
was my best I wasn't injured like that
was the that was the best me and Zach
was better like that first loss it
didn't bother me I was like I mean I'm a
competitor so I don't want to lose but I
was like it made me it's gonna make me
step up right the next one the
guillotine that eats me still wasn't it
quick it was quick so I I went out kind
of LAX I usually like come out pretty
aggressive and I went out kind of
relaxed and he he rushed me uh and he's
like 15 and two he's a good record but I
feel like I should have beat him like 10
out of 10. and uh he rushed me and I
went back against the fence and I fell
and uh and I like thought that I
couldn't get need or anything so I
reached for his legs and he need me but
not with a knee with a quad so it was
legal and uh and it and I woke up in a
guillotine I guess I got up and I did
two I did two singles put him down with
two singles on the second single the
first one he came back up the second
single I did I didn't remember doing it
that was like out but it's muscle memory
man you just oh so you were on the
ground and he needs you but he luckily
for for him hit you with his thigh and
not his knee and so they've declared it
legal yeah and he probably meant to do
it that way I don't know I don't know
but uh but I woke up in a guilty I
remember waking up dreaming I was
drowning and uh and that's that's uh and
I was like what happened man I couldn't
believe I lost that fight and I had like
all the brook Army Medical Center
brought like the whole Wounded Warrior
unit there they had all these guys there
like in wheelchairs and from the burn
unit they were all there and I like ah
it hurt it stung
um you did win again May 2012 you win
Legacy FC
um North South choke round one as a UFC
vet Joe Sandoval that's a good win
uh what I think was your last Pro fight
was
2013 October 26 World Series of fighting
and you won again with the north south
choke yeah that's my joke that's your
joke we need to do a private and you can
give me your details I tried to get GF
with it uh Jeff real oh Jeffrey you were
coaching against it I couldn't get it on
him okay yeah it's messed my choke and I
was trying to get it on him and I
couldn't get it on him oh that's good
I'll get everyone with it and he and I
get everyone with it and I was in a
position for it and he escaped oh Jeff
said Jeff's a freaking Scrappy kid man
yeah who won that I did did you did you
win by points or judge or whatever
judge's decision yeah yeah that's the
one that's one of those ones where they
hold up the flags at the end yeah yeah I
remember that was that fight to win yeah
something like that what year was that
oh gosh I don't know like five six years
ago seven years ago
um now during this time you're you're
doing Mighty Oaks you're uh you know
you're obviously still fighting you and
and with a Z's you're
kind of keeping intermittent calms with
him because you know all the stuff's
classified and you're just not wide open
talking to them
your son's going to Marine Corps yep
um which is awesome how do you feel
about that man I was I was super pumped
uh because you know fam my oldest son
Hunter always wanted to be marine and
then the family footsteps you know he
wants to work in Mighty Oaks one day so
he's going to Bible College and then
he's like I want to go to Marine Corps
he wants to be a Recon marine and not to
talk to him because he's like I also
want to be a husband and Dad I'm like I
shouldn't pick being a Recon marine and
so I I I've kind of like sat down with
him and figured out what he liked most
and he was super interested in aircraft
so I showed him about anglico which is
like the jtac little small four-man
teams that go in bed with four Nationals
and he loves working with other
countries so I thought man you could get
to work with all the different foreign
militaries get to call for fire uh call
an air support so that's what he did and
he ended up deploying the Afghanistan
with the with the Georgians with the
Jordan he was embedded with the Georgian
infantry sure so he got to actually even
in 2018 he got to actually go in and do
kinetic kinetic operations call in fire
support
and then what about your other son he
went in to be a uh he went in to be
crash fire rescue so he had always
wanted to be a firefighter my wife's
family's firefighters there you go and
uh so he did a little merger of both and
he actually got out with the max he did
not want to get the backs and uh and and
I supported him he was he was kind of
worried that our family would end 84
years of service with that you know and
I'm like hey man like uh if you're doing
it for the right reasons and that's your
convictions like I'm gonna I got your
back and and what about now are they
gonna let him back me in or whatever
they're asking him to come back in now
oh yeah so his was called a other than
honorable discharge oh come on uh for a
commission of a serious offense and uh
but we had like some serious like
consultation you're down in Houston
we're in Houston yeah is that Dan
crenshaw's freaking District it is yeah
you give give Dan a call man that's
totally ridiculous it is other than
honorable yeah yeah and he was like
honor grad at a boot camp like I mean I
mean squad leader at boot camp undergrad
I was in West School like he he uh
he did he's like he was you know and he
was about to get married towards promote
Corporal and and they were like then the
backs came up
so so he did uh he did uh religious
exemption and then they did the appeal
and then the appeal to the commandant
and then when he went to do the appeal
to the SEC secondary uh secretary Navy
they wouldn't send it up and uh so he
filed like The Whistleblower thing and
and reported a commission uh reported uh
unlocked water because of some of the
the details about the vax was you know a
lot of people would agree with unlawful
order and so that was kind of end of it
for him to discharge him well
but he'll probably go back in good I
think he's gonna go back into reserves
good for us to finish
um so you're doing all this stuff and
like I said your your Communications
with disease relatively you know
intermittent at the time
um and again you got a bunch of details
about all this lessons that you learned
along the way you know in both these
books and you have another book too
which I got the Kindle version of I
don't have and now it's called Never
unfair Advantage
um that's really really cool kind of
focused on your on your work in in uh
Special Operations
um but I'm gonna fast forward now it's
summer of 2021. um
Biden has already announced that uh you
know America's gonna leave on this date
regardless of what the circumstances are
that's when we're leaving things are
going things are going south they're
going south quick
um I'm gonna go here to this is chapter
five of the book and and it's it's
the name of the chapter is is who
surrendered to the Taliban
so here we go based on reports I heard
from contacts in Afghanistan the Taliban
seemed emboldened following the United
States not date not terms announcement
the Taliban was starting to sweep its
way across the country with Kabul it's
winner take all target although we were
still committed to the SIV process and
that's that's a special immigrant visa
for aziz's family and again I fast
forward through a bunch of stuff you've
had stuff you've already done you're
working to get them out you're you're
making connections you're trying to make
it happen I'm fast forwarding past that
stuff uh the situation on the ground was
more severe than we were hearing back in
the States I called congresswoman vitzy
Vicki Hartzler a member of the U.S House
of Representatives from Missouri and a
wonderful woman and leader we had worked
together through Mighty Oaks foundation
on policy related to faith-based
solutions for veteran care I informed
representative Hartzler of the
incredible service Aziz had provided for
our country and that although he had
reapplied for the SIV status on July 1st
2021 he could not get into the U.S
embassy in Kabul because of the covid-19
restrictions we have to help this guy
she told me representative Hartzler
committed to doing what she could to
push along his application although I
trusted her I had no faith in the actual
SIV process I knew I needed to go into
Afghanistan and bring Aziz and his
family out
my teammate Andy and I had already been
discussing possible options for saving
Aziz at the end of our one of our phone
calls I said I wanted to move forward
Andy immediately said he was on board
and fast forward a little bit here I
pitched to the proposed I pitched the
proposal to Richie McGinnis a journalist
with the Daily Caller who had
interviewed me for many stories about
Mighty Oaks and Veteran issues I'd
enjoyed working with McGinnis I
respected him and like me he loves a
little Adventure I just got described
from McGinnis how his organization would
be our cover by saying they were working
on a story out of Afghanistan regarding
the withdrawal they would hire me as
their consultant Andy as head of
security and disease as a local culture
expert after getting what we needed in
Afghanistan for a piece we would fly by
private jet to Dubai for completion of
the prod production work but we would
need Aziz and his family to accompany us
to be interviewed for their story
then Aziz and his family remain in Dubai
and of course never returned to
Afghanistan
McGinnis was all in for both the story
and to get Aziz out and his boss is at
the Daily Caller granted our plan an
enthusiastic green light I crunched the
numbers and estimated our operation will
cost 65 thousand dollars I believe God
has an impeccable timing on how he
orchestrates events that same day I
received a call from Wayne Hughes Jr a
Dependable friend advisor and long time
generous supporter of Mighty Oaks Wayne
had read an article about a special Army
special forces guy who wanted to get his
interpreter out of Afghanistan do you
know this guy Wayne asked I want to help
with this Afghanistan thing and I'm
thinking about giving to this I don't
know him I told Wayne but I'm actually
wanting to do the same thing for my
interpreter I was literally planning as
you called why didn't you tell me he
asked I explained how I appreciated
everything he had done for our
foundation over the years and didn't
want to ask for anything more how much
do you need he asked about sixty five
thousand dollars I replied Wayne
responded without hesitating done
so that's like your initial plan that's
the initial plan yeah
pretty good plan it was yeah I thought
it was good and uh man Richard McGinnis
was uh he was on all that stuff he's
seen on Fox like undercover with antifa
and BLM that he was under he was a he
was uh embedded with them and he's like
a pretty cool guy and I was like man
he'd be down for this and they talked to
cut they talked to Tucker and
everybody's like yeah that sounds like a
great way for us to get a story whatever
they do they do like whatever we did you
know but they're like it's a great way
for them to get a story
and uh
um
then I mean things just start moving
faster
on August 11th the media reported that
one U.S official uh admitted Afghanistan
could follow the Taliban within 90 days
I'm gonna fast forward a little bit on
August 12th so that's August 11th then
on August 12th in our minute obviously
we all remember this happening but it's
interesting when you hear the dates on
August 12th the Taliban was taking over
so quickly they now face no resistance
the Pentagon announced the deployment of
3 000 U.S troops immediately to evacuate
diplomatic Personnel from the U.S
embassy in Kabul not that a defeat would
have been admitted but sending troops in
after declaring the withdrawal of our
military had to be the last thing the
White House wanted to do the withdrawal
wasn't transpiring as planned
unfortunately the mounting problems were
so predictable
the following day Kandahar fell next
Marissa Sharif the capture of
Afghanistan's second third largest
cities on consecutive days revealed the
taliban's military strength because the
a a still maintained an operating base
in Kandahar the Taliban had to go into
those places with a militant Force
intimidating enough to compel resistance
fighters to surrender so this was just a
freaking disaster across the board
um
fast forward a little bit more and again
you give great detail you have you have
a very cool perspective that you put in
the book because Aziz is there you're
talking to them so you're getting his
perspective it's a great way you did
that in the book
uh you say the results of the White
House not having a plan unfortunately
manifested on the events of Sunday
August 15th a sad day in the histories
both of Afghanistan and the United
States the Taliban took over the capital
city of Kabul that day with no
resistance
president Ashraf ghani I want to do like
an entire series of podcasts about this
this
miserable human being fled the country
hauling possibly close to 170 million
dollars with him we later learned and
the Afghan government collapsed Afghan
and what's funny about God you know
ghani was like a a professor at Berkeley
I think where he taught like how to save
failing countries he taught this course
and and you know he just ridiculous
Afghan government collapsed Afghans
flocked in the thousands to Kabul
Airport looking to escape also that day
the American flag flying over the U.S
embassy in Kabul was lowered
and the embassy evacuated
you're going to say in in 1975 the U.S
military pulled out of the Vietnam War
but the diplomats contractors CIA
employees and Marine guards remained
behind when the North Vietnamese took
over South Vietnamese capital of Saigon
A hurried Mass evacuation of Americans
began the final American Saigon were
first forced to evacuate via helicopters
Landing in the embassy's parking lot and
on the roof the word humiliating is
often used to describe that moment in
U.S history five weeks before we
evacuated our Kabul in Embassy President
Biden had assured Americans there would
be no such repeat of History
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof of the embassy of the United
States from Afghanistan he said
obviously we all saw those pictures
Kabul was Saigon all over again contacts
on the ground were telling me that the
Taliban had surrounded our Embassy and
weren't allowing Personnel out Embassy
workers could not get into a car and
drive four miles to the airport they had
to be flown out via helicopter
how we left the embassy proved the
Taliban was calling the shots and they
knew it
we did not hand over the embassy to the
Taliban no diplomacy was involved
helicopters flying off the roof is not a
peaceful transition that's a retreat the
Taliban took our Embassy from us
August 15th was a day of defeats Afghans
lost their country to the Taliban for
Americans our military did not suffer
defeat but the U.S government with blood
on its hands lost to the Taliban
yeah
freaking ridiculous yeah I think one of
the biggest lies the American people
were given with Afghanistan was that we
were in this 20-year War this endless
war that we had to leave
and I think one of the things president
Trump could have did in 2018 was
declared the war over and shifted to it
and announced the support and advisor
role because that's what actually
happened so in 2018 most most Americans
don't understand this but we we were we
moved to support an advisory rule of the
Afghan National Army and Afghan National
Police and the International Community
all participated and we were we did it
at Bagram Air Force Base which is the
most strategic place in the globe right
now between Iraq Iran Russia and China
and uh and and it was working we were
supporting and lifting up the African
National Army to keep the Taliban at Bay
and keep terrorism where it belongs in
the mountains of Afghanistan and not
hearing out and not become a global
threat or national security threat so
like this push to withdraw from
Afghanistan was uh just a lie I mean
it's not even consistent with our
traditional like military strategy uh
We've we have 80 000 troops still in
Japan since World War II and 48 000 in
Germany 35 000 in South Korea we had 2
500 troops at one point in Afghanistan
why would we want to give up that base
and and in doing so so we didn't even
talk to Nato we didn't talk to the
Afghan government we put in place we
talked to the Taliban our enemy of 20
years that we did this Doha agreement
which the Doha agreement basically says
that they won't allow terrorism they are
terrorists and uh we've seen right away
they're you know they're starting to
execute people day one as they're coming
out of Pakistan they're I mean it was it
was just insane to me
yeah
um
when you're gonna when you're gonna
support a country that's trying to
change the way that that you've lived
you it takes generations to do that and
right you pointed out to three examples
right Korea Germany Japan you it takes
generations to get them to be stable on
their own and that's what it takes but
we weren't fighting a war anymore in
Afghanistan the war that we had been
fighting
was over was over you know we hadn't
taken casualties I think we hadn't taken
a casualty in 18 months something like
that so those the war was over in 2500
troops we have that in 10 places right
now Djibouti Africa oh yeah Syria
they're all over the world that's not a
lot of troops uh and you know it's so
the idea that we don't understand
sustained Wars these contingent forces
prevent prevent Wars it brings stability
in regions and so for us to give up I
mean now we're looking at potential war
with China without even a strategic
location like I'm there China China
actually is who's occupying the base now
not the Taliban ridiculous
um
fast forward a little bit in the book as
rapidly as the situation in Afghanistan
was spiraling out of control an effort
to save Aziz was coming together an
equally stunning fashion so quickly that
it could be only described as God thing
orchestrated in a Divine way that I
could not explain and give us a brief on
who Andy is yeah well Andy is like a
long time friend he was uh he was on
that first Jason task force with me and
uh just a lot of experience and uh he's
the one actually recruited uh Aziz in
the first place to bring him on with us
got it so you're working with him again
and you say Andy and I started
connecting with our network of operators
who might be interested in going into
Afghanistan with us we specifically
wanted guys who had deployed to
Afghanistan were from the Special
Operations Community had a real world
soft experience and most importantly had
a heart to rescue vulnerable people
instead of look to get in a fight with
the Taliban to sow their War lust oats
we ended up quickly assembling a core
group of operators who were highly
experienced trusted and rightly
motivated yeah I think it was a big
thing that we were looking for so I
didn't want anyone to go there like to
go get some right so that this isn't the
place for that you had 20 years to do
that like right now we're going not to
be combatants and that was very
important to pick mature guys and so we
had some uh we had uh you know a couple
of NSF guys Recon guys some guys from uh
from ground Branch uh that was that were
able to be part of our team and a very
experienced group of guys all had that
same kind of passion and motivation that
we had just to go do the right thing and
that's why I called it we all like
pretty strong people of Faith to thank
everybody we call the task 468 from
diverse Isaiah 68 here mice and me and
that's what we called it and uh and you
know it was all originally all just to
go get his ease and his wife and kids
but that changed obviously you uh talk
about in a key person and not just the
operators but you say God started
bringing groups of like-minded people
together and we began consolidating our
efforts one such person was seren
verardo Sarah verardo whom I met through
the mighty Oaks Sarah's husband Michael
was catastrophically wounded by two
separate IED attacks in Afghanistan in
2010. the blasts took Michael's left leg
and much of his left arm he has endured
more than 100 surgeries plus years of
speech visual physical and occupational
therapies for his body and traumatic
brain injury Sarah became a champion for
wounded veterans and their caregivers
through volunteering with the
independence fund she eventually became
the fund's first CEO in addition to the
direct help
the independence fund provides wounded
veterans and their families Sarah has
become an effective influencer in
Washington DC of national policies
related to Military and Veteran causes
as I worked parallel efforts in DC
through Mighty Oaks Sarah and I joined
forces over the past four years to
impact veterans Health Care policy and
uh you know so she plays a huge role in
this huge I mean she's she's very sharp
she's very connected and obviously she
has a a very personal vested interest in
in Afghanistan I mean her you know she
you know pretty much lost her husband uh
you know or lost you know who he was
when they got married and she's like his
caretaker now like and uh so she was
very uh it was very passionate about
this and so she was one of the first
people that I that I connected with in
this because I knew she had the ability
to move the needle and making things
happen access is important especially
when you're in a DOD control the
evacuation so access is important so I
knew she could help with that other guys
you know Tim Kennedy nick palmisano uh
guys I can't mention their names uh I
mentioned Joe Robert's name uh but some
really uh incredible group of guys and
you know as we're putting this together
uh one of the guys picks up his phone
and puts it down and it's like uh hey
this uh this is 30 500 orphans and they
just got left
me because people are surviving like
they're the 35 provinces fall people are
surviving so like these kids just got
left like uh you know Andy and this guy
Sean were like we need to go get these
orphans and that's kind of shifted from
let's get aziza's wife and kids but
let's get as many Americans interpreters
their families women children that'd be
perfect Christians that'll be persecuted
this gives me people as we can we have
like this incredible group of people
we're all willing to do it let's just go
all in and uh and that's what I said
we've got a lot of credit like we got
recognized on the house floor we got I
got that Bonhoeffer Achievement Award
like we got all these things but the
truthfully like the only thing I feel
like I could take credit for is that we
were just we had that burden of we've
got put in our heart and we said yes and
beyond that like I'm not smart enough or
capable enough to pull off what happened
because it was like it was literally
like some things happening like that's
why I said the only way to describe it
was like a Divine Miracle because if any
one of those things didn't happen the
way they happen in a sequence of events
it would the whole thing would have been
fall apart no the first was Sarah
calling uh The Joint Chiefs and getting
permission for us to build to go in a
DOD controlled H Kaya airport how many
cars that in National Airport as
civilians to possibly land like
commercial aircraft or form military
aircraft and go outside the wire to
rescue people like that's like a I mean
you're an offshore that's like a no
that's right that's like that's a no
exactly and uh but but in a miraculous
turn of events they said yes and then we
had to figure out how to get people
these are Visa applicants now like so
they said yes but we have to be able to
give our manifest to the Joint Chiefs
they have to prove so we have to be very
diligent in who we're getting how we're
getting them have a bonafides process to
prove rapidly who they are and then we
have to be able to move people that are
Visa applicants across the border of
another country we can't bring them to
the United States because we're not the
state department so we have to find
somewhere to take them because that's
human trafficking and the only place you
could do that is like Laredo Texas I
think but outside of that in the real
world you have to follow rules and so we
called the royal family we had some
people that need a royal family of the
United Emirates and we asked for
permission we're on this phone call for
like an hour and I thought man he's no
one's saying anything I'm like they're
just rolling their eyes like these
idiots like but at the end of that phone
call they were like we'll roll out the
red carpet we bring them here we have a
humanitarian Center we have doctors food
facilities we're going to take care of
just get them here and he said if you
need an aircraft we'll give you a C-17
plane the large military aircraft with
pilots and if you fill that one up it'll
give you a second one and then the third
thing that happened was Glenn Beck radio
show host a friend of mine Glenn Beck
called and he said Chad I just got into
radio to raise money I thought I could
raise a few thousand dollars because I
just want to do something so he got
behind his microphone he said three days
I raised 21 million dollars overall he
raised 46 million he's like well I don't
have operation so I said start
chartering planes and so Mercury once
his non-profit they partnered with us at
Mighty Oaks and they started chartering
a guy named Rudy atala who's a better
amazing dude start chartering planes for
us it's all that came together in like
three days to launch this operation yeah
it's freaking it's crazy I mean like
it's it's a crazy amount of stuff and
you got great you got stuff about the
team in here you got Andy
um you got Tim Kennedy you know what'd
you say about Tim uh member of US Army
Special Forces Greenbrier sniper top 10
UFC fighter well-known TV personality
from History Channels on Hunting history
history uh series and discovery's hard
to kill and a guy just crazy enough to
try anything once
uh and then you say the main reason I
reach out to Tim because he's a trust
quote uh friend and a legit operator
Beyond Tim's celebrity profile is
extensive training Real World experience
and soft operations he's not a has been
he is still that guy and currently
serves as special forces uh operation
sergeant
with the 20th special force group Tim's
like I don't know I don't know how Tim
does what Tim does he gets a lot of heat
for like being like people go after him
but man people don't realize he's like
he's legit like operating gross
absolutely absolutely uh you know like
you said you got Nick Paul Machado um
parmigiano uh he's another guy that's a
stud you know he's a ranger West Point
guy
um super smart yeah I mean you just put
together this guy sea spray
sea spray was the Kingpin of a lot of
this and what would some of the stuff in
Ukraine highly intelligent guy Green
Beret you know you served with you know
the premiere like Special Operations uh
in in the Intel side he's
he lost 37 pounds in the 10 days we were
on the ground doing everything he did
not stop like he didn't eat didn't stop
he just like kept going out and getting
people it was he's an incredible human
being yeah and then your son Hunter yeah
you know so he's like he's like this
well he's like he's like Dad I'm gone
okay I'm getting ready and he's like
what are you talking about go to your
room like like he's like he's like you
know I'm I'm a I'm a man now I have a
beard like I've been in Afghanistan like
I had an interpreter too like I want to
be part of this and I'm like and so I
just kind of thought for a second like
man like how horrible would it be for me
to like take that away from him you know
and uh I mean obviously I don't want him
involved in this because of his dad I
want to protect him but how horrible
would that be to take that away from him
and me have to face that Noah took it
away from him for the rest of his life
so so you know he ended up in Abu Dhabi
really just he's a super smart you know
kid and he's like he just really
organizes things really well so he was
like and he kind of earned his place
there in Abu Dhabi and then and then
ultimately he wanted to come in the
river operation with me but we didn't
let him do that but but now he's like in
Ukraine like he's leading operations in
Ukraine he's he's free smart you've got
it going on yeah uh he's a black belt
too
it's definitely got it going on
um fast forward a little bit again get
the book but I'm gonna fast forward a
little bit here after Kabul fell the
first part of our task for six eight
which you already talked about that's
from Isaiah 6 8. uh here I am send me
um Team headed overseas to set up a jock
in the UAE and again the UAE been you
know the they're they're fighting
terrorists in the UA the UAE is staunch
allies of America
um so it doesn't actually surprise me
that they were ready to support
I remain in the United States for a few
more days to continue working on
Operations Logistics for when the team
arrived in Afghanistan and to work with
Sarah setting up the system for the
flood of requests coming at us because
that's another thing that's going on and
you talk about in the book like now
listen everybody knows that you're gonna
get people out everyone's putting in
requests to you
uh Sarah worked the DC angles taking
responsibility for coordinating with
government officials to ensure we did
everything legally we were carrying out
a moral cause rescuing rescuing our
fellow man and we knew he had to
precisely follow the law
uh you go on here as of Friday August
20th we estimated a hundred thousand
Americans and allies needed to be
brought out of Afghanistan the next day
Sean sea spray and Dave flew from Abu
Dhabi into Kabul as our first boots on
the ground Tim and Nick would fly later
into the UAE with Hunter and me and then
Tim and Nick would travel on to
Afghanistan once we had everyone in
place Andy Joe Hunter and I along with
others would work operations and
coordinate rescues from The Jock and Abu
Dhabi Sean sea spray and Tim would be
our three-man Rescue Team working
outside the airport while Dave remained
inside hkaya in uh to coordinate with
the military Nick would spend one day
helping Dave and then return to UAE to
work with us so dude this is like an
incredible logistic freaking effort oh
it's like it was like saying so fast and
it was like
yeah yeah oh and then like I said if any
one of those things
if you were if you were to say Hey
listen I want you to evacuate uh 50 000
people from a country how long do you
need to plan and execute this you'd be
like I need six months yeah Adam that's
if you were good yeah look I need six
months so the fact that you're doing
this [__] in three whatever it is four
days something like this six days is
absolutely freaking awesome
um yeah it's just everybody just coming
together
uh it was one of those moments there's
always a little bit of ego everywhere it
was one of those moments that Arrow I
put all that aside and just worked
together to do the right thing and I
never knew there's no time for there was
no time to like prepostering a position
I was just like let's just lock arms and
do it that was rad when we had Tim on
talking about this like you know Tim is
just such a good such a good dude but
he's like yeah I'm glad this happened
when he you know he's glad it happened
when he was however old he is now 31 7
or 41 or whatever he is he's like
because he just was like okay what do we
need to get done whereas if he you know
if he was young if he would be young Tim
yeah which young Tim had to be a handful
we laughed a bunch about what a handful
Tim young Tim was
um but yeah just the the fact that it
wasn't just him but everyone on the team
have all these badass experienced people
and they all like what do we need to get
done no egos let's rock and roll that's
that's what made it happen absolutely it
was it was cool to see Tim that way you
know I've been knowing Tim for a long
time and Tim was just like
like what do you need Gary like what do
you need like he he was like where do
you need me and uh and and honestly it
was like when you join a ground team and
he was like he wasn't going like seeking
and everybody was giving a hard time for
that like he was just like where do you
need me and he was just there to help
and uh and by the way like he didn't
need to do any of that he's like he's
pretty successful too yeah he didn't
need to prove anything he's got he's got
the profile he's got the bio like he's
got a successful he didn't need to do
anything for sure he just want he just
wanted to help just trying to help out
yeah
um
and and for me like one of the other
benefits for me is that I know when I
was putting this together like this is
going to cost a lot of money and I have
to raise it fast and uh you know I
already have like Mighty Oaks I have to
raise six million dollars a year like
um for Mighty Oaks like I need somebody
else that could help be in the pr side
and so Tim wore that I had to true and
damn Glenn Beck raised what 26 million
46 total uh 21 in like three days and
those with those flights like a lot of
people don't realize those flights were
like eight hundred thousand dollars a
piece you know props to uh obviously to
Glenn Beck that's awesome also to the
American people that are like oh I can
afford to give a little bit to help
these citizens out help these allies out
that's why I like I keep saying as I
talk about this like so there was a time
where we're in Abu Dhabi
and uh it was it was really perplexed by
this because they had helped us rescue
uh get some Americans out right and so I
I was in this room and we were a couple
of us were in there there was a minister
of interior there was a five generals
there was uh 20 something lawyers in uh
and a couple of royal family members and
I had to thank them
uh rightfully for helping us get these
American Americans out when our
government wouldn't and then I also had
to apologize for our government which
I'm a pretty proud patriotic dude so for
me to apologize for our government was
like something hard but uh but as I
walked out I remember walking out just
feeling ashamed and uh and then I
thought for a second like you know what
I'm ashamed of art of our government but
I've probably never been more proud of
of being an American because when the
government when our government did not
do the right thing good people stood up
and just did it and I don't mean just
the 12 of us that went to do the rescues
I mean like the thousands of people who
donated uh the the people who just there
was people that that don't like me that
follow me on social media because they
don't like maybe my conservative
patriotic views and they go so there
were people that were following me that
was writing me like hey I don't like you
but what you're doing is awesome where
can I support like like you know people
like that and there was a Jewish
organization that went to donate uh
write about in the book they went to
donate uh 1.5 million dollars for two
flights so 700 000 flight 800 000 flight
and they were going to donate Mighty
Oaks you know we're a Christian
organization so they went to make the
donation and they called me up and they
said hey we can't make the donation I
was like did I give you the routing
number wrong like like no you're a
Christian organization we're a Jewish
organization we can't make that
transaction and I said man you okay but
do you realize we're rescuing a Muslims
right and here like the guy like laughed
and he's like okay let's do it and a big
donation it was like really cool moment
to see just people from all walks of
life just come together do the right
thing for the fellow human and it was it
was it was pretty cool and you know and
again the government didn't do the right
thing but but people did yeah it was
cool
man
um get a little picture on the ground
here I'm gonna fast forward a little bit
um you you got the at this point where
I'm fast forwarding to the Taliban
basically has
external perimeter of H Kion so they're
they're around the airport they
definitely control a lot of perimeters
they control the Outer Perimeter um we
barely control the inner perimeter uh
and you say I've flown in and out of H
Kai many times the international airport
is on the northeast edge of Kabul and
densely populated residential areas are
to its Southwest and Northwest but
they're also a bit of a buffer of open
terrain around much of the airport the
Taliban could not stand shoulder to
shoulder to secure the airport perimeter
because it was far too large of a land
mass
imagine the a major airport where you
live you could cover access points and
observe open areas but the perimeter
would be porous
the best way to locate the checkpoints
was good old-fashioned walking and
looking with the Taliban executing
people trying to escape the worst
scenario would be for our Rescue Team to
start smuggling people through an
airport gate believed to be secure and
then have the group compromised by the
Taliban so you got people trying to
Recon trying to figure out what's going
on
uh I gotta fast forward again but here
we go I had to do so you're you're
communicating with Aziz and you say I
had to do a lot of convincing for Aziz
to make his eighth and he said final
attempt to reach the airport so he's
tried a bunch of times to get through
there's checkpoints everywhere
um he's getting shot at he's got a
dimash course seven years old or six
years old at a time his wife has a wound
uh infected appendix wound from surgery
like it's so he's got all that going on
uh you say because of the Taliban check
points to zero Zero's presence massive
crowds the first seven attempts that
failed Aziz had lost Hope on the seventh
at night I coordinated with Sean who was
waiting for the family at a gate when
Aziz called and said they were turning
around he was covering seven-year-old
mascaralla's ears while talking to me
and I heard shooting in the background
I'd heard shooting on the previous call
too I just need you to go for it I
pleaded with Aziz with Bashir and his
towel band thugs looking for Aziz and
his family and again the backstory on a
lot of this stuff is in the book
um Bashir obviously a bad guy
um I believed it was more dangerous for
them to turn back but Aziz also knew the
accounts of what the Taliban were doing
around the airport they were beating
people they were shooting them to death
they were cutting off heads and arms
they were tying a rope around people's
necks and dragging them behind cars
through the streets
I can't brother he said moscowala is
scared I've got to go back Aziz didn't
believe his children especially the
youngest ones could take hearing more of
the gunshots the Taliban were firing
into the air to scare people or Worse
they'd witnessed the Taliban strike
people to the ground with the stocks of
their guns they'd been pushed and shoved
within thousands of people outside the
airport Afghans had heard on the news
Aziz said that the United States said it
would accept anyone who worked for its
government and also anyone who'd not
worked for them as Aziz put it the
people thought the door to Paradise was
open and being the closest to the
airport Gates was their only chance to
get in
man what a disaster
Aziz made attempts during the night and
day by different routes and entrances
but nothing had he had tried worked
after the seventh attempt he said the
airport was too dangerous to try again
so he would try and come up with a way
to leave by foot into a bordering
country
I didn't think Aziz could make it out of
Kabul alive
he had already been turned back at two
Taliban checkpoints and I didn't like
his chances of avoiding being recognized
a third time or being found by Bashir I
asked him to go to H Kyle one more time
I trust you brother you said I'll try
one more time
so you're just like begging him to try
and get there I remember telling him
like Bro you've done I've seen I've seen
you do
harder stuff than this you you could do
it you like even if not for you for for
your family like you have to get them
out I was like pulling that like do it
for your family like like muster it up
man like like you got to keep going and
he was like he said his like legs were
so weak that he could barely even stand
up he was uh you know he talks about a
lot it's like if it was just him you
know he threw guns in the back of his
truck went to the mountains and resisted
but he's got he's got his kids he's got
his wife and I mean there's one moment
some of the stuff's not in the book but
he was like at his house like
putting guns and and grenades and places
and saying okay if they come from this
way you got his wife here he's got his
daughter here he's got a son here like
covering all their acts his family left
everyone left him so like his family
like wouldn't disassociate with him so
he's like by himself and and um you know
so he's like pretty desperate bodies
he's draining every day you know that
the energy is draining out of him he
just just kept having to you know to try
to keep him motivated try one more time
yeah and it's one thing to risk your own
life which you can do pretty easily but
when you're risking not just your life
but your white life of your wife and
children yeah that's a different and
he's got this stuff playing through his
head he knows what's gonna happen
they're gonna like rape his daughters
and you know and he's gonna you know
torture his family in front of him like
he's you know he knows what he's facing
it's not just like being killed that's
that kind of that's that weight I fell
back you know back in 2007 when when I
was dealing with the stuff I was dealing
with I wasn't worried about getting
killed I was worried about being in the
bottom of the basement at my feet
smashing my sledgehammers like those are
the kind of things that really
you know kitchen that's what he was
worried about yeah and it's real easy to
sit here and um
you know be distant from this stuff oh
look you oh you saw it on the TV you saw
someone getting you know they're getting
shot getting executed
you're on you're watching on TV you know
or you read about it like they this is a
real thing that they are watching
they've seen it they know what's
happening well they're seeing there's
bodies everywhere people trample people
shot uh they were taking babies like and
what the level of desperation wasn't
just people climbing at airplanes and
like imagine a mom like taking their
baby and knowing that this baby is going
to either become a sexual slave because
it's a girl or it's going to become
pushing the madrosses and become a
Taliban you know evil evil terrorists
because of the Taliban takeover so now
your baby's only chance is to get it
over that wall of the airport so these
moms are kissing their baby goodbye
putting it on top of a crowd of
thousands of people to be crowd surfed
to that wall and whoever at the end of
that they got to somebody would grab
that baby and throw it as hard and high
as they could to get over that wall and
a chance for survival that's like the
level of desperation what they didn't
know was on the other side that wall was
six feet high and 20 feet deep of
Constantino While My Buddy Joe counted
six babies that have bled out in that
wire uh because you know when costume
wires cramped you can't really uncrimp
it so babies are uh and there is it's
just that's the level of desperation so
he's trying to get his family through
that and uh you know people with Taliban
shooting but he was he got shot at by
the Taliban he got shot at by the double
zero units the Marine shot at him
because he's like you know Chad robbery
show like he's look him up on Google and
they're like get the hell out of here
man like we don't know Chad Rover show
like and then Marines are shooting yeah
um
going back to the book here you say I
messaged Sean and got on a call with him
to tell him Aziz was in a different
location and that Aziz would not be able
to stay there long enough for Sean to
get him Sean called inside H Kaya to the
senior enlisted leader of a U.S Special
Operations Team master sergeant Hy
who had been helping us Sean briefed him
on Aziz and Hy agreed to go to the north
gate and meet Aziz and bring him inside
we linked everyone up through WhatsApp
and Hy told Aziz that he and his team
were on their way to meet them outside
the airport the area was relatively calm
allowing Aziz to wait there he spotted a
small pair Rescue Team exit the north
gate across the road from where he was
standing about 50 yards away but they
were wearing body armor and helmets and
Aziz couldn't recognize if it was H Wise
group Aziz climbed onto a large shaky
Rock and while trying not to shift his
weight too much and flip the rock over
he yelled Hy Hy this is Aziz but Hy
didn't hear Aziz then as he saw a
teammate next to Hy get his attention
and point toward Disease by now Aziz had
raised the awareness of zero zeros and
Marine securing the gate the zero zeros
push disease trying to get him to back
away from the area a few Marines came
over and shoot his ease away Aziz tried
to show them his documents I'm your ally
he told me I worked for you guys I put
my life on the line I worked for Chad do
you know Chad robichow
I don't know him one of the Marines said
get away
someone from one of the groups fired a
warning shot in aziz's Direction then
h-e-l Hy yelled across the street that's
my guy don't shoot him come over here Hy
shouted to Aziz Aziz sprinting across
the road and embraced Hy my family's
over here over there Aziz said pointing
to the open area in the distance I was
not able to bring them it's very
difficult to get here I need your help
please tell the Marines and the other
guys to let me bring to my family the
warning shot had brought attention to
that area more zero zeros came rushing
in and zero zeros of security force from
the Afghan government
um and they're do and both them in the
Marines are trying to like keep things
secured
which you think well the weren't they
trying to help them no they're actually
trying to keep people away from the
airport because there's so many people
flooding the airport because of this was
such a disaster
um some were fine you're firing into the
air that spread out the crowd that had
been stirred up by the first shot some
Were Striking people with their guns to
try and control them amid the growing
commotion Hy got the attention of a zero
zero Commander Hy and his team had
already gone against orders by coming
outside the airport gate look this is my
guy Hy told him he needs to bring his
family here walk with him and escort him
all the way through through your guys he
and his family are very important okay
their Commander responded I'll walk with
him to that area where our guys are but
I'm not going to walk him over to where
the Taliban are the commander and Aziz
started walking toward his friend's car
please don't leave Aziz told the
commander these other guys do not know
me they won't let they won't let me come
back the commander accompanying disease
as far as he said he would which was
about 20 yards from where aziz's family
waited Aziz feared that if he walked
away to get his family the commander
would leave Aziz called his friend and
asked him to drive the car to a spot
across from the street from Aziz in the
commander the friend allowed Aziz
instructions the friend followed
diseases instructions and disease was
able to walk to the car while nervously
keeping an eye on the commander to make
sure he didn't leave Aziz realized that
bringing his family together across the
street could get would get the taliban's
attention a family moving together
obviously be trying to get to the
airport instead one by one attempting to
blend in with the surroundings so he
could not be recognized as he slowly
walked all seven members of his family
from the car to the commander the
commander then returned with Aziz and
his family to where Aziz had met up with
Hy Hy and the team came back outside the
gate in an armored Hilux pickup truck
and they heard they look loaded the
family and the two bags They Carried
with them containing all the possessions
they were hoping to leave their home
country with inside the pickup and sped
inside the gate
when the Hilux had cleared the last of
the various checkpoints maintained by
Allied militaries Hy snapped the selfie
with Aziz and sent the photo up to us
that's when I learned that my brother
and his family had finally finally made
it safely
into age Kaya
there's a part that uh that is not in
the book that we could say now about
about two hours after Aziz got in there
got his family situated uh we got worded
as a
a 16 year old American University
student was trapped just outside in a
house just outside of Taliban was trying
to find her she was hiding she tried to
climb the wall and fell so she was
injured couldn't move
and uh and we asked disease to go back
out I didn't ask him but uh some of our
guys asked because he used to go back
out and uh and go get her and he did
yeah I was actually upset when I found
that yeah I'd be pissed too but uh damn
but but that's just who he is you know
he was like his wife's like you're
coming back out he's like no no I'm not
going back out and he went back out and
got this girl it's wild too like the
modern technology that you get us you
get a freaking selfie like as soon as it
happens yeah I was like I remember
seeing that I was like oh my gosh like
just like it was just such a relief
because I you know as optimistic as it
was so it's like it was really hard to
keep hope like it was
it was crazy I mean the whole situation
was just so crazy
um fast forward a little bit
coordinating rescues from home in real
time made me want to be part of the
rescues on the ground from 150 rescues
the first day we jumped to 800 the
second day and set a daily goal of a
thousand on the third day Monday August
23rd Tim Nick Hunter and I departed for
the UAE
so you guys that you had done that all
that from the ground in America yeah
where I was putting I was just burning
the keyboard man like uh getting
everything together orchestrating
everything and you know what's weird
what I remember like this stuff happened
so fast so I I'm I I like go on social
media but I don't like go on it yeah I
like post my stuff or whatever but by
the time I realized what you guys were
doing it was over it was actually over
it was like literally over by the time I
was like hey you know I saw you know
save our allies like somebody tagged me
in something or whatever and it was I'm
pretty sure it was actually over by the
time I call wind of what was going on
but that's how it happened it just like
happened so quick yeah um yeah I did
that you know so I was the first like
few days was you doing it from my house
and then then I flew over to Abu Dhabi
and uh and then ran everything from Abu
Dhabi and then uh and then you know that
whole 10-day period at airport and then
two two months of Mazda Sharif and then
the then Tajikistan River operation in
Afghanistan Tajikistan so it was just
like yeah the whole thing was about
three months I don't know if you tagged
me in social media or Tim did or
somebody did and I like reposted it or
something but you guys were already like
working and uh at least I I ca I can't
remember it all but I just remember
going damn this is because I also
remember sorting through there was a
bunch of people that were kind of like
your buddy that said hey the Special
Forces guys trying to get some of his
friends out like so many people yeah so
many people were asking for money yeah
and I I I was like trying to figure it
all out and then when I when I found out
was you guys when I found it was you and
Tim I was like okay cool that's at least
a known good group of freaking humans
um but yeah this [__] happened quick
um fast forward a little bit more
we traveled to Abu Dhabi and by the way
your job was done too you know like you
got your friend out your job was done
but you were just getting warmed up we
traveled to Abu Dhabi where we were able
to grab about an hour sleep we woke up
and met with Tim Nick and Joe to plan
out our initial integration to
operations there a flight was bound to
uh about to return to age kind about an
hour or two and since Joe and Andy
needed me in the jock it was just going
to be Tim and Nick on that flight to
join Sean sea spray and Dave saying
goodbye to Tim and Nick as they departed
brought back an old feeling I had to
experience in years the last look you
give someone before they go and you know
there's a real chance you'll never see
them again
I couldn't help but consider they were
getting on that plane because I'd asked
them to and they trusted me yet I had no
control of the environment they were
stepping into Tim usually loud joking
and always having fun but his tone was
serious this was real and our lives
would all be in danger along with those
we were about to save Aziz and many
others whom we didn't even know I looked
at Tim and Nick one more time as we
walked in opposite directions and prayed
to myself God be with them blind the
enemy miraculously protect them and give
the give us success to save these people
when Tim and Nick arrived See Shawn and
sea spray were on their way outside the
wire within 15 minutes of stepping off
the plane Tim had changed clothes and
our three-man team was leaving the
airport for the first time together that
night they set up eight rat lines
including ones that passed through the
sewage ditches that were received
attention on the news reports the gate
the UN accessed had been sealed shut
when the UN left the country Tim cut off
a couple of locks and bent and cut some
rebar so the gate could be pried open
just enough to move people through
the team also made cutouts and fences to
pass people through so there you go man
the boys on the ground making happen 15
minutes after they get on the ground
they're rolling out
everything was so fast the whole time I
remember I was my first deployment to
Iraq there was a there was like a qrf
was needed it was far away and uh one of
my buddies who was my senior enlisted
advisor who's uh for our task unit it
was just like one of my freaking awesome
Bros and this we were launching this qrf
it was a bad situation and we like I
what I told my guys was like Hey Loadout
and full Loadout everything just ammo
there was like a a a CPA was getting
overrun down south so when you're when a
physician's being overrun yeah and
you're going as a qrf like you know it's
on but I remember my but my buddy had
that like look like I'm like all right
bro I'm out of here and he like hugged
me and I was like oh [__] it feels like
this is worse than I thought it doesn't
look that's when I when you were reading
that I was like you probably know what
I'm talking about like when you just get
a look you're like man you might
might be the last goodbye
um yeah
fast forward a little again you go
through such good detail in the book
most of our operations occurred
undercover Darkness although we were
able to move larger groups during the
day by bringing them to the airport on
buses as with everyone we brought into
the airport we made triple certain
anyone we allowed onto a bus was
properly vetted the US government has
been accused of evacuating lucky Souls
who were in age Kaya regardless of
status while that may ring true our
efforts were handled with military
Precision our government was adamant
that we weren't sticking just anyone on
a plane and flying them out of the
country most ngos working alongside us
did due diligence in vetting people as
well we knew exactly who we were getting
out because of the triage process that
Sarah oversaw in the states
so you guys ran this um
you know like a like a military
operation yeah I mean those I mean as
you you could suspect on the ground you
know is of course the near Four
recognition symbols in it with the
bonifides process to make sure they're
they always say they are before we move
them and then of course they're going to
bring they're going to have 10 if you
have 10 people you have another 10
people that that shouldn't be there and
so you got to sort through sort through
that
um
fast forward a little bit more
late afternoon on Thursday August 26th
at 17 50 local time of the bid suicide
bombing outside Abbey gate
killed 13 U.S service members and
approximately 170 Afghans hoping to be
allowed inside the airport
18 other U.S military members along with
well over another 200 Afghan civilians
were severely wounded
when I received ward in Abu Dhabi the
attack my first thought was are our guys
okay
we immediately got in touch with Tim at
the time of the explosion our ground
team had just completed loading evacuees
onto a C-17 about a mile away they had
been at abigate minutes earlier
the cargo ramp was still down on the
plane when they heard the blast and the
dust plume Rose from that area they
could not tell what had happened but
they knew it was bad
they closed the ramp right away and sent
off the flight
as the reports came in detailing the
number of U.S service members killed
I got angry
yeah
I mean anybody that made it in and out
of the airport was because the Taliban
allowed them to and for the White House
to immediately say that was Ice Isis not
the Taliban is like how could you defend
the enemy that way to the American
public
you know it's uh you know we allowed
that to happen
and we know you know the biggest and I
talk about in the book the biggest thing
is that Neo operation you you take the
White House took the non-combatant
evacuation operation away from the dod
and gave it to the state department who
has no business in doing that they don't
know how to do it it's not their job to
do it that's what's the difference
between military force and diplomacy and
uh they treated that airport like an
embassy and it allowed a military to do
their job they just made them Embassy
guards yeah and that's that allowed this
to happen is it
a a lance corporal in the Marine Corps
would have been able to plan this better
than the way it went down and it's just
it's it's horrible to see and no and
then I mean no offense to Lance
corporals in the Marine Corps at this
time
um because you guys are squared away and
you have done a better job 100 percent
um
fast forward a little bit more the
bombings aftermath created more
challenges for us with a week remaining
until the United States self-imposed
deadline two more gates were welded shut
further restricting entry points we also
received word from inside the airport
that military leadership that started
pulling back troops from security
responsibilities which was one way we
were able to bring people inside
the new challenges meant a mix of overt
and covert operations was no longer an
option for us at H Kaya the additional
security threat forced us to work
covertly
and avoid all major Gates
for whatever motivation the statement
Department had I think it figured out
that the only way to shut down NGO
evacuations was to allow the lily pad
countries to max out on refugees they
could handle the vetting processes to
move refugees out of those countries
came to a virtual hole our last flight
of evacuees left three days before the
deadline
for that time the rescues were over
Tim Sean spree sea spray and Dave
returned to Abu Dhabi and we reunited to
share a meal holding a debrief hold the
debrief and address what was next for us
I had badly wanted to fly back into
Afghanistan one more time even if just
to help load evacuees onto one more
plane I had wanted to put my feet on
Afghanistan dirt one more time
but over 10 days when the dust settled
we had rescued more than twelve thousand
people out of Afghanistan with the best
I can estimate over 50 recovery
operations
only the Department of Defense evacuated
more people
and
we save disease
so
yeah
um
so when that when that piece happened
we knew like
the military had to leave but we we kind
of remember us talking and we're like
well we don't have to you know the uh we
knew the everybody that moved to Mazda
Sharif also the White House was saying
there's a hundred Americans left which
you know that the state Secretary
blanken had said there were 16 000 and
they said they moved that six thousand
but now there's a hundred I'm not that
great at math but but I'm better than
that right now and but it you know we
knew for a fact there were thousands of
Americans still there and uh and but the
truth is you know it doesn't matter if
there's a hundred or a thousand like you
don't leave one American behind that was
even a promise that President Biden had
said himself you know and we're you know
we're from where we came from you you
know he was scorched the Earth to go get
an American like that's just what we do
even in some idiot like Boomer doll a
traitor like they knew they would lose
people to go get him but he was an
American they were gonna go get him and
so we chose to stay and uh because of
that and um you know we worked a
Coalition in Mazda Sharif and got
another we got another 5 000 people out
through that
and then when that was over
um after two months of that
basically all the the ability to be able
to fly people out like I said the state
department pretty much closed those
doors so we knew that it still had to be
something we could do
um everyone had moved to the Pangea
Valley and Ahmad Masood of anybody's
followed the history of Afghanistan 911
Ahmad Masood was the leader of the
Northern Alliance in Bin Laden
brilliantly assassinated him the day
before 9 11 because he knew he would be
our Ally so they cut off our allies
before he did not did executed 911 which
was you know pretty pretty smart
strategy and then also that was kind of
this race uh that moved that movie 12
strong that was this race to get control
of uh of the Ally Force like build Ally
forces against the Taliban taking them
because of the assassination Mama suit
well his son uh his son started the
resistance in the Pangea Valley so all
the Commandos that we trained moved
women and children to pancher Valley and
they were they we had heard they were
planning to cross them in the tajika
stand for for refuge and so when I heard
this I'm like this is what we could do
because I knew I've been the area plenty
times before the mountains there like 25
000 foot Peaks they're uh the even if
you make it to the Border there's like a
hot a lot of places like a thousand foot
cliff off the Border because uh the
border of Tajikistan in Afghanistan is
the Pangea River so there's like a lot
of cliffs there and in addition to that
the Pangea river is category five Rapids
it's ice melt water if it stops anywhere
it's freezing even in the summertime so
it's like this really treacherous
Terrain in addition to that the Taliban
was protecting that border the tajik
Border guard was protecting there the
Russian military moved in and had like
mechanized convoys up to like 45 bmps on
the border to keep people from going
into Tajikistan and then the Chinese
military had deployed their like Chinese
infantry they had Special Operations
units to make sure that no one crossed
so they were going they were gonna try
to move women and children through all
that with no kind of visual another of
how to do it and so that's kind of bread
and butter for you know Force Recon guys
and I'm like we need to go across and do
route Recons and do some forwarding reps
and provide that information we had some
contacts in our government agencies
government intelligence agencies that
couldn't collect that information but
they wanted it and so uh so we decided
to launch a two-man operation and uh and
that's what another miracle happened I
called uh there was a marine named
Staffordshire and Dennis Price and he's
uh he just came from jsoc Force Recon
team leader year Scott sniper younger
than Mesa camera stuff like like uh you
know he's just like a really good dude
and he really wants to participate and
so but he the problem was he was in the
reserves and you wouldn't they wasn't
allowed to participate in anything like
this so I called his Commander
Lieutenant Colonel Tommy Waller who have
knew I said hey you got this Marine
there staff sergeant price what are the
chances you could cut him loose to allow
me to come in this humanitarian Mission
that's what I called it and he said uh I
put it in writing I don't know and so we
put it in writing and another miracle he
got approved and uh he he got cut loose
to come with me and uh so when he and I
went and and did this you know operation
spent 10 days
we traveled you know we landed did 12
hours drive through mountains on that
border no it's uh again all this is in
the book
um you know you you you you have
updates in there from Afghanistan that
you talk about which are very powerful
to read like the one that I remember was
uh you know like 11 year old girl that's
being forced to marry a 55 year old man
this is what's now they're they're
suffering under there and then like you
you know you go into the details around
this this you know uh this Tajikistan
mission where you got like Nikita this
tour guide like it's wild uh border
security encounters
um you got all that stuff the
assessments that you guys do so there's
a whole nother story like you know I
stopped when when when you saved disease
but that's not the end of the book
um you got discussions about the meaning
of the war in Afghanistan you've got
Aziz back in America with his family so
there's so much more that I covered now
or that we covered today
um but you know you close the book by
explaining
that there's still 40 million people in
Afghanistan living under this oppressive
tyrannical regime the Taliban
and then what you say is that
despite the people that we were able to
get out
because there's millions of these people
still there well you say in the book you
say we cannot claim victory there is no
victory in all of this there's only
doing the best we can as the mission
continues
and that's for sure I mean
the reason I want to bring that up is
not only is it true in this situation
but it's it's true in so many situations
that we all face in life yeah which is
you face dire situations you face
incredible odds and sometimes the best
you can do
is the best you can do you're never
gonna be able to raise your hand in
Victory and say I'm the champ but the
best you can do is the best you can do
it applies to war applies to health it
implies to business it applies to life
yeah so I I thought that was a a really
pertinent part of the book
to to bring up because it's not just
about this it's about everything yeah I
mean like
a lot of people have given us a lot of
credit you know 17 000 people out that
sounds like a lot but that's a speck of
sand on the beach compared to the 40
million there the 20 million women and
little girls are sexually Enslaved the
rest of their life they don't even have
women's rights they don't have human
rights now because of this and so like
17 000 sounds like a lot but to me it's
like
what if we could have done more uh you
know and I vividly remember like pulling
as we're in that Operation Center like
we're doing we're planning operations
pulling white papers off
of the board that I like this white
paper would be pulling off and throwing
away because that mission didn't happen
because we couldn't get another we
couldn't get our guys another another
500 yards closer to these people and now
it's 300 kids that were just tossing
that and moving it on like there was so
much more we could have done and I mean
in the river operations you know Denison
swimming across that River every night
into Afghanistan and uh and then that
was one night we were trying to rescue
his family this pregnant woman and a
Commando and their their kids and it's
like that didn't happen there was so
many like
parts of that book the book that I wrote
about in the book and plenty of that
aren't in the book that were just like
not victories but it was just the best
we could we're just trying to do the
best we could and uh we keep we keep
getting asked a lot like we've done a
lot of Media stuff and me and sea spray
were on an interview recently and
this lady was asking us like why you
know why we do it I mean obviously why
we get a diseases you know that's I
think most people could conclude why
wouldn't go get a Seas but why do we
stay why are we in Ukraine right now
helping in Ukraine you know we don't
know these people and you know I think
the simple answer is because it's the
right thing to do and there's never a
wrong time to do the right thing uh if
you can help someone if you have the
ability to help someone and you you
should but sea spray was asking another
question and it kind of took me back
when he was asked luckily had asked him
because he answered it perfectly that
lady said was it worth it and he said it
doesn't have to be
right it doesn't always have to be worth
it to do the right thing and I think all
oftentimes our life we look at
everything like with the ROI like I'll
invest my time my energy my money my
resources what am I getting out of it
what's the risk you know what's the risk
analysis you know it it doesn't always
have to be worth it to do the right
thing we think a risk me and Tim
specifically were getting insulted a lot
like on social media I try not to read a
lot of stuff but people were like you
got like basically like champ like
hoping for us to die so we learn our
lesson because we shouldn't have been
out there getting away in the military
first of all like the female I think we
got in the way of the military like who
is stupid enough to believe that we had
a bunch of veterans have the ability to
land on a DOD control and do that on our
own like cowboy thing it's that's
impossible right we clearly had
coordination and secondly like you don't
think we know the risk we all been
around a long time we knew exactly the
risk uh we were taking I didn't I mean I
mean I remember like me and Dennis
flying over to tajika's Dan like we're
about to swim across this River in
Afghanistan like my wife that we're on
the way to airport she's like why are
you doing this like again I mean she was
you know she was worried obviously
scared and she's like why are you doing
this I'm like what if it was us what if
this was our daughter that was gonna be
sexually Enslaved the rest of her life
what was it our sons that would be put
in this position we'd be praying someone
would come help us
and uh you know I know I would and uh so
you know sometimes I think in life
outside of combat outside of stuff like
this Afghan just everyday life this you
know we have the right the opportunity
to do the right thing we should and you
know I think really this was a lesson
that I learned in that and doesn't
always have to be worth it the ROI
didn't have to always be there we
measured that a lot you know what we do
but sometimes you know like sea Spurs
said it doesn't have to be worth the
right thing yeah well I would say that
the ROI on doing the right thing is the
most valuable thing that there is it's
just just that compared to have a look
at yourself in the mirror when you know
you didn't do the right thing that's to
me that the ROI on doing the right thing
is the most valuable possible Roi there
is that's true you might not be able to
measure it out in you know some kind of
monetary value or whatever right but I
mean if if everyone was just driven by
what their Roi was in terms of material
things I mean life would be totally
different and it wouldn't be good yeah
um so
let's talk about like okay what do you
got going on right now what's so save
our allies that's up and running how's
that going is that what's is that who
you're in Ukraine with right now no so
um so you know Mighty Oaks Foundation my
Foundation we stood up save our allies
as the effort for Afghanistan
um I I was when when that was over we uh
I stepped off the the board with safer
allies because I I'm too focused on
Mighty Oaks I have to be uh so it's
still up and running Sarah nick uh Tim
still still doing safer allies and
that's save uh save our allies.org
okay and so for me Mario Oaks is a is
and we have international Vision we're
in Ukraine uh doing
um what we call a medical Mission uh so
we go out and bring the troops like ifax
and go we'll teach them like T Triple C
um you know combat combat casualty care
and then and use that as a rapport
Builder with them to build to be there
for them uh in a mental spiritual
program side that Mighty Oaks does and
so we we take our Mighty Oaks
instructors U.S combat veterans who have
been trained to do Mighty Oaks and push
them forward and small teams to do that
we've also been involved in a lot of uh
rescue operations some would save our
allies and and uh and then others
without uh we just um rescued Benjamin
Hall if you remember the Fox news
reporter was catastrophic I wounded it
was myself sea spray and a couple other
guys uh went and and took it uh Benjamin
Hall out then the following days after
that we went back and uh I actually
drove the Hearst out to get a Pierre the
25-year cameraman
um out of a Kia when it was under attack
and went out to the front lines Clarke
all the Darius is zoom
um and we we I've been like two hours
past the Russian line uh doing some of
the programs we've been doing so we've
been we've been out there doing some
pretty incredible work in Ukraine when's
the last time you were out there uh two
months two and a half months ago how was
the morale for the Ukrainian troops man
you know it's pretty crazy because uh
they're they're like so optimistically
motivated and uh they're they feel like
they're in such a righteous position to
defend their homes you got to take the
politics out of it because everything we
see here in America is like soinski and
and billions of dollars and all this
corruption and stuff like that I don't
care about any of that stuff I care
about helping people and most of these
the troops in Ukraine they're not tied
to the Ukrainian government they're
there like to protect their homes their
families and yeah and their wives and
kids so when you look at from that
perspective these people are like
they're righteously feel like they're
defending their their way of life what's
the were you able to get a feel for the
morale of the Russian troops uh the only
Russian troops I've seen firsthand and
uh and that was dead or dying we were
into Zoom we were in a zoom uh uh and
they pushed the resume had been taken
for six months so the Ukrainian unit
that we were with pushed forwards myself
in sea spray just two of us and uh we
were with them when they pushed forward
and the Russian line collapse behind us
uh so that's first time I've ever seen
air over us like I they were like two
like
and they're like were those migs and I
was like I've never seen that before in
Sea sprays like yeah me neither and they
came back and did a gun run in front of
us uh and then uh they were IDF hitting
like 100 yards of us we were stuck there
but as they push forward I probably
counted like 60 Russian troops that were
dead or dying so how'd you get it out of
the envelopment well which once it
settled we were able to move out we were
you know single vehicle we were just us
in a single vehicle so we just had to
wait for it to
to calm down we stayed with the main
unit as they move forward we were with
uh we had the with us was the uh the
chief of all the Ukrainian police
so it so he had his detail with him
that's who we were with but uh had to
wait till I mean because that like I
said the line closed behind us and there
was that was probably probably the most
kinetic fighting I've ever seen um you
know I'm you know especially considering
the type of work in Afghanistan I've
never seen that level of kinetic
fighting firsthand before but
you know I mean like we were walking by
like and they were like a Russian kid
like probably 17 years old
dying and they still had his AK-47 on
him and I took it from him and and
cleared and cleared it because their
Ukrainian troops already passing I
didn't pick it up and I'm trying not to
be a combatant there but but like that
close to kinetic combat I'd never seen
anything like like I could show you some
videos on my phone like like it was
crazy
I mean and this is uniform or uniform
you know we haven't seen much of that
before
um and so uh
obviously we're not there trying to get
involved in those kind of environments
but the nature of the work that we're
doing puts us in those places sometimes
we just uh I don't want to say the name
but um but we just moved out we were we
had a seal that was fighting there and
uh he was he was wounded we were moving
him we went into we were called to go in
and get him we went in and win to get
him and uh
this is not an active duty seal no yeah
just to make that clear yeah sorry yeah
he's uh joined the Ukrainian Legion and
uh to fight there and he uh but he was
going to we were and then we stopped to
the hospital and uh he was he was being
treated at the hospital and the state
department gave some problems at moving
him and so he had he would have we tried
to get him to pull in for help but he
ended up passing and uh we got his body
out so we'll be doing things like that
as well and so we were able to get his
body home to where his family wasn't so
he could have a proper burial and be
back with his mom so
yeah the um
the outlook for the war in the Ukraine
in Ukraine
um
you know it's a test of Wills and as you
mentioned it's very difficult to break
the will of people who are defending
their home and their families that's
right and their soil
so you know you don't know who's gonna
and I'm surprised well I guess I'm not
surprised
we don't learn this lesson we meaning
human beings don't learn this lesson
right because we think we can go to some
other country and by we again it could
be anybody could be anybody could be
America like we did in Vietnam like we
did in Afghanistan like like the
Russians did in Afghanistan like we like
big giant countries have done all over
the world
go in and think we can beat someone
because they're small and because uh
we're bigger and we have better
technology and the fact of the matter is
you're going to come up against people
that are willing to die
for their cause
and this is what happened in Vietnam you
know we we looked at them and said we
can kill after the battle of the I drank
Valley we said oh we killed 150 of them
for every one of us we can win
and what we didn't realize is they
didn't care if they lost a million which
they did two million we lost 58 000. and
we lost because our will was not in that
fight yeah and I think that's what what
you're getting to with the Russian
what's their their motivation I mean
most of them don't even realize their
conscripts they don't realize why
they're there some of them think they're
going to eradicate neo-nazism from
Ukraine some of them think they're going
there for a training exercise and so
they don't even I went into I was in a
went to a jail cell with about 10 of
them and they were just uh they had just
been recently captured and they were
just like
what do you want to know like we didn't
want to be here and uh but I was I was
in this I was in a safe house
with uh with this Ukrainian pastor we
were when we first went there one of the
things we did we set up a community kind
of clandestine communication
infrastructure for some of our assets
and and we were sitting there just
talking and uh and I was like asked him
the same question what do you think is
going to happen and he said uh we're
gonna win and it was just said it was
such confidence I'm like and he's like
they would they will have to kill every
single Ukrainian to take this country it
ends up I mean right now it's like you
said it's uniform on uniform but if
Ukraine uniform forces let's say they
lose which is but by no means going to
happen but even if they did they're
gonna have to fight against an
Insurgency that's going to be there
that's gonna you which is going to be
very difficult to defeat yeah we drive
we drive like we usually move at night
and uh and we have the usually both the
roads are closed but we have the ability
if we have permission to drive a night
but sometimes you run into
like we have permission to drive at
night but just if you're hitting an
official military checkpoints but like
I'm driving through we do like 18 hour
drives like like cross across Ukraine
and we're driving and then there's like
another checkpoint it's a militia and uh
you know they're not connected to the
military they're protecting their homes
and towns like like you're saying and I
mean that's the scary that's one of the
most dangerous moments for us because
they think we're they're told that gay
Russians will come through here the blue
American passports and they'll say
they're in ngos and they're gonna kill
you so now we're in the middle of the
back country by some country boy with a
on a 55 gallon drum next to a fire and
he's got his he's got his hunting rifle
and a machete and they got us you know
there's a the whole crew around us and
they pulling everything out of car and
they they think we're going to kill them
so they're scared which makes a very
dangerous environment but I mean these
these people are just they're just
wanting to protect their homes
all right man
um does that get us up to date kind of
yeah I mean uh you know obviously Mighty
Oaks uh always and though especially
with your platform there's any veterans
out there First Responders active duty
service members spouses that need help
like no you're you're not alone you
don't have to do it alone you were meant
to do it alone like uh so many amazing
organizations out there Mighty Oaks is
one of them everything we do is free
will fly you out we have an amazing
program where are they located because I
used to be in California is there still
one there's one in California Central
California we have 25 000 acre ranch up
in Paso Robles area we have two in Texas
Virginia Ohio
um and so uh but how many programs are
you running a year there we'll do 35 uh
camps this year and uh how many people
in a camp uh all the locations are
different but average of 40 people but
21st time students will go through
because we we have guys coming back
through that leadership development
because we training guys to be part of
it so be 40 beds but about 21st time
um people coming through and if the
faith-based thing is like a turn off for
people like I could tell you to half the
people that come to our programs not you
know that share our Christian faith but
they come and you know take what you
could take from it and it's a it's a you
know we're not it's not an Evangelical
like pushing Jesus down your throat
program it's like we used to we use our
faith-based side is like biblical living
so we kind of like contrast making good
decisions based off these biblical
principles but you know don't let that
turn you off and uh and keep you from
getting help we have amazing group of
people it's all peer-based uh there's no
counselors there not anything against
clinical counselors but that's just not
what we do it's peer-to-peer mentoring
and uh people that have been through the
same things that you may be struggling
with and could help you move forward
what's uh this is mighty
oaksprograms.org is the website what's
uh what's the course look like how long
am I going there for if I'm if I if I
reach out first of all how do I reach
out go to the website yep go to the
website uh applications on there super
simple application we made it make it
that way because we'll get more
information later but uh we want to be
an easy application process someone from
our team will contact you back uh within
like within a few days three or four
days and then we could uh we have the
certified camp this year so we'll
schedule your location and date that
works for you and by the way we don't
care about your discharge if people you
know sometimes people I know I know guys
are you know Navy cross recipients I got
a bad conduct discharge to DUI right
that doesn't mean we don't help them so
like it doesn't matter we don't care
about any of that stuff and uh so you
you go you'll come it's five days long
you'll spend five days on our Ranch uh
uh well five nights so six five nights
six days and you usually get there
Sunday night and leave leave Saturday
morning and uh and you're gonna be
putting a six-man team there'll be a
better uh you don't have to be a combat
veteran to go but all about team leaders
are combat veterans and uh so a combat
veteran who's been through a program
trained bus will lead that team and
you'll go through 14 uh 14 like core
principal courses and at the end of each
class like their classes are in
different kind of life like life
principles that you would uh and and we
go you break out in that six-man team
and you just kind of work through that
together what's it look like in your
life what's how that challenge in your
life with some better decisions you can
make we help people make a plan in to be
able to navigate the hardships and
difficulties of life and make better
decisions and then part of that plan is
using our Aftercare system to have
someone to stay connected to and have
support all the way through so when I
leave
I'm still connected that's if I have if
I need help I got a buddy that we linked
up with maybe somebody that's further
along in the program that type of thing
that's right yeah that's what as our
Aftercare program I think is one of the
most important things that we do and
it's one of the areas I think a lot of
organizations and programs fail at they
have this you bring people this program
you have this kind of mountain top high
and you go back and life hits you right
back in the face you know and they don't
have the resources so one of the things
I thought early on you know that that
made me successfully in the successes
I've had personally was the having that
support network moving forward so I knew
that we have a program like this we have
to have that integrated we should not we
should not outgrow our ability to have
that system of Aftercare and so if we
can't have that system of care we need
to and we need to grow at the
organization I've always made sure it
grew at the pace that we were able to
maintain a system of Africa so now
people have to choose to be part of it
you know and obviously like anything
else people could sign up for Jitsu and
choose not to come uh but uh what just
happened happens a lot and probably big
strip big part of your Revenue stream
here to school
so so uh I mean you know people sign up
for things and don't stick to it but but
we hope but even even so you know like a
joke uh joke about that but the truth is
like sometimes people leave the program
and it'll stay connected and they think
they fell off and then they'll struggle
again they'll come back they know where
to come back to and and having that
Lifeline knowing where it's at is
important as well
so you do both that program and the
stuff that you're doing overseas for
instance in the Ukraine right now is
that are those all under the same uh
non-profit yeah so mighty Oaks
Foundation has four four areas we do a
resiliency program that's usually me or
Jeremy Stone that could go on the bases
around the world and speaking uh on
resiliency to the Troops so like I go to
Marine Corps boot camp I do
pre-deployment briefs I uh I've been nsw
uh resiliency programs I've done a lot a
lot with army SF so we do those I've
spoken about half a million troops in
the last 12 years doing that really in
about the past six years and then in
that we give we've written a lot of
resources I could send you some of them
we have these little books that are
about 40 or 45 minute reads we have one
on PTSD we have one on uh on spiritual
residency oh you know those four pillars
they see Mind Body social Spirit the
spiritual pillar and then we have one on
suicide so we have these resources we've
given away about 350 000 copies of our
books doing that and then our recovery
program is a legacy program that's the
camps we're talking about and then the
third thing we do is a public policy I
I'll go I've spent a lot of time in DC
like testified before Congress and
Senate working with the the VA to get
faith-based programs uh make sure that
veterans whether people agree that with
faith-based programs or not I think we
could all agree that veterans should
have the freedom to choose that if they
want it so really fighting for that in
DC and then the fourth thing we do is
our International and so we take those
same programs that we do successfully in
the states and bring them to our Ally
Partners around the world so Ukraine's a
little bit different because it's active
War right now but we were in Ukraine
before this we we had done three trips
there helping them recover from 2014. we
would Peru uh different other Ally
countries around the world we take those
programs and we kind of like a train to
train our model like Hey we're gonna
take my this is what we do in the states
for Mighty Oaks for our U.S service
members let us do one we'll go there and
do a resiliency program and then they
can identify uh some staff members and
we'll train them how to do what we do
and hand it off so that's what that's
our International effort when it's
typically what it typically is like I
said Ukraine's a little bit different
right now
yeah no it's freaking awesome work and
like I said I've I've seen what you've
done uh with guys so I really appreciate
what you're doing there save our
allies.org you also got Shad Chad
robichow.com that's where if people want
to if you want if you're looking for
Chad you want to come speak uh
you know that's where you reach out
um obviously you got your books on there
as well what else what else is on that I
mean the other thing is mighty
oakprograms.org you know those those
three locations and uh and it might be
at my books speaking I do a lot of
speaking and there's primary one of the
ways to raise money to do you know get
well even when I go out speak I'm do two
things in one raising money to be able
to pay for these programs and make them
free uh for people and then uh because
we we do about half you know about 500 I
mean five million dollars a year in
programming and then the other the other
side is I go speak and it helps me
broadcast just like right now I'm
getting to broadcast what we do so
people that need help could find help
you know and it goes I speak at a lot of
churches on the weekends we do a lot of
corporate events and there's corporate
events they have a lot of Veteran
employees there and we always get
applications after I speak when I go to
church on a Sunday and speak we'll get
swarmed with applications because people
in their Community are struggling and so
it's bringing them a resource so that's
through uh chadrovershow.com uh you're
on social media yeah Instagram is the
most active most active on Instagram
that your Instagram is Chad robo
r-o-b-o underscore official
uh you are also on Twitter just Chad
Robo and you're on Facebook Chad
robichow
c-h-a-u-x for those of you that aren't
from from Louisiana
uh and you got a YouTube channel too
Chad Robo three six three five one
what's six three five one uh I don't
know that was me that one's yeah I
looked at it there's videos of you out
there oh man I gotta check that out all
right
um awesome six three five one six three
five one I don't know I figured it was
some MOS or something no I don't know
just random numbers all right well we'll
figure it out you're not born in 1963 I
don't know six three five one uh does
that get us up to speed yeah yeah pretty
much there yeah man I appreciate it
probably a good place to wrap up Echo
Charles
no fighting questions I mean we're still
doing Jiu Jitsu right yeah of course
well there you go yeah all good uh
really impactful story though yeah I
thought yeah anytime when like you kind
of fall out with you know members of
your family and then you could reflect
back of you know with with the stuff
that you did or didn't do and you can
come back together I think there's
always like some kind of lesson in there
and even on like sometimes you go deep
like you know like yours was like
detrimental yours was like near the end
kind of a thing like it doesn't even
have to get there to learn these lessons
you know like you can just be the
smallest little thing and be like hey
wait a second I learned from you know
that story or whatever kind of implement
that way of looking at it and boom bring
it back and and get everything together
there's always something to learn with
that you know what I was thinking of
when you were talking about your wife
like after you guys split up and you
were like not being a good husband at
all and then you guys are trying to get
back together and then sometimes she's
like hey you know what you come home and
she's like I don't want you you know you
disgust me all that stuff and uh you
know you're going to your friend that's
kind of mentoring you and I what I was
thinking I was like if I was mentioning
hey bro this is a test yeah like this
you you this is a test that you have to
go you know we talk about gamifying
things and how you turn something into a
game if your game is like okay I'm
getting oh this is a test I'm getting
hit with right now because my wife who I
was an idiot too is now testing me out
and testing out my faith and testing out
my temper and testing out my ego
and I'm not going to pass this test or
not that's the question I remember like
literally pulling in the driveway and be
like like I like I always talk about
making a pre-decision uh like you decide
in advance you know decide a moment of
chaos right and so make it I thought
about that and I'd like pull in the
driveway and be like okay I don't know
what I'm walking into a woman that wants
me in the house and loves me or a woman
that's gonna like be crazy and try to
stab me with a kitchen knife I don't
know what I'm walking into but whoever's
gonna be in that house I'm gonna have
that compassion and Grace and and uh
making that pre-decision in advance yeah
I actually talk about that when I'm when
I'm working with leaders
uh you know I say hey before you know
look it's hard to detach it's hard to
not let your ego get involved so before
you go into a meeting with your boss
that you know has a bad temper or a
meeting with your employee that you know
has a big ego before you go in there yep
decide how you're gonna act before you
get in there say to you okay these are
the things I'm gonna work on I'm not
gonna let my ego I'm not gonna get
emotional I'm not gonna speak when I
shouldn't be speaking I'm gonna listen
like whatever those things are that
you're gonna do
make that decision before you get into
the scenario right you're gonna have a
much better chance of success yeah
that's a good plan you park your car
outside the house it's immediate action
drill right yeah and then you know what
you're gonna you don't decide that you
don't decide in that moment of chaos you
don't decide like hey call combat
timeout rally up figure out what to do
you know exactly what you can do because
you thought about an event you practice
it you rehearsed it a thousand times
when my parachute fails I'm not I'm not
having to think about what I'm gonna do
yeah I I know what I'm gonna do I don't
have to think about it uh awesome Chad
you got any closing thoughts man no man
I'm just I'm super grateful if you had
me on uh it's been you know something
I've looked forward to for a very long
time and I think we have me on you got
an awesome show you're doing you
crushing it man you're doing inspiring
people doing great things it's an honor
to be on with you well thanks and I'm
sorry it took so long to get you down
here and I'm sorry you got a uh bad
teeth or whatever you said you can't
train right now good
um really appreciate you coming down
thanks for thanks for sharing your
Lessons Learned thanks for your service
you know obviously in the Marine Corps
you know what you did as in the Marine
Corps what you do as a contractor but
really especially for everything that
you did for our allies in Afghanistan
and for what you continue to do today
for our allies overseas and especially
what you're doing for our veterans here
at home thanks for everything brother I
appreciate it man appreciate it right on
and with that Chad robichow has left the
building
a lot going on there Echo Charles yeah a
lot of
ups and downs
yep a lot of
losing oneself and finding oneself yeah
fully so uh a lot of it
coming back to jiu jitsu you know what's
interesting you know no one knows what
happens when we when when when someone
leaves the building yeah but we actually
just went out and reviewed some Jiu
Jitsu moves a little lesson still in the
game you know yeah Chad's still in the
game still training so getting after it
teaches sometimes when he can
and what a good
grounding right you know it's a good
thing to come back to the Jiu Jitsu yeah
hopefully it's weird like one of the
many things that dawned on me yet again
with like the story like okay yeah the
the shooting incident right but the
Afghanistan stuff like he's going
through it right saying there's how
everything like got laid out I live in a
bubble I understand
and this stuff is like this is really
really happening it's not like it's not
just a novel it's not a novel it's not a
movie or whatever this is like really
happening yeah that always uh kind of
kind of blows my mind a little bit yeah
uh and I try to point that out too like
you're reading the book and you're
hearing about people getting shot and
people getting drunk through the streets
you're kind of like oh that's you know
that's like you know you you might say
oh well that's like this movie that I
saw so you're taking a book and relating
it to a movie you know the movie's not
real so basically you're just distancing
yourself from what's really happening
right and it is when you think about the
fact that
this stuff is happening that you know
guys are going into Harm's Way and what
does that do well it's not you don't
know what's gonna happen man you do not
know what's gonna happen yeah so uh yeah
man also to the um
it's it's a it's an interesting because
I don't know you know I watched TV
sometimes and you know you see stuff on
the news and like all the stuff and you
have this this kind of picture laid out
but he kind of
it dawned on me that like sometimes when
like things aren't being done the
correct way even though that's normally
how they go like if you know where
whether there's a lot of red tape or
it's just some a big bureaucracy or
whatever but sometimes you can just
freaking grab a friend two friends 10
friends ask some people for some support
on the tail end on the front end and
freaking just do it yourself
I was gonna go into this whole
comparison this is like free market
opportunities right it was like the the
big bureaucratic thing which is the
military in the state department was all
you know they've got planners and
they're doing all the stuff free market
was like okay we need money we need
people put them together who wants to
rock and roll let's go do it and they
wouldn't do it yeah so yes uh sometimes
you just gotta get after it and that's
what's gonna work so while you're
getting after it you need some fuel get
yourself some Jocko fuel go to
jocklefuel.com look we got all kinds of
good stuff drinking some right now
drinking some go energy drink hard to
call it an energy drink when it's not
really comparable to normal energy
drinks that are poison and will give you
diseases
yeah over time they're they're
absolutely horrible for you factually we
got something that's good for you so go
there jockofuel.com you can get
do you know what joint Warfare you can
get Curl oil super cool you can get Mulk
ready to drink Mulk okay so here's the
thing about milk here's a new
development in my workflow my Mulk
workflow so
you know how like sometimes was it
Dakota Meyer said he froze it's frozen
yeah
good good move so here's the thing
incidentally this is what I found so the
RTD Mulk you don't freeze it but you get
it really really really cold like right
below freezing
than drinking for real and you'd think
like okay it's just cold or whatever but
it adds another like um layer of
something whether it be flavor or
Texture whatever like how cold it is
it's lit it's like you know you guys are
saying like oh yeah the vanilla one
tastes like melted ice cream it is it's
like actual ice cream yeah so it's like
you know you have this impression you
know when you drink stuff like water you
drink under certain circumstances it's
going to be more appealing than like
juice or soda or milk or milkshake or
ice you know all this stuff when you
drink the fro the the what do you call
just below Frozen one it's like it takes
you to a different context
bro I'm telling you try try I'm gonna
try it yeah I'm gonna try uh
jocklefuel.com go check that out you can
also get it while while you can get a
vitamin shop military Commerce we have a
bunch of friends sending me stuff for
military commissaries pictures of it
like yo you got it in here so Hannaford
Dash stores HEBs HEB sorry HEB down well
I guess it's heb's plural down Tejas
Meyer out in the Midwest
Weiss just rolled into Weiss some lunch
places
um if you if your store doesn't have it
ask for it Jocko fuel
uh there you go also origin USA if you
need a pair of jeans which you do if you
need a pair of boots if you need a pair
of
shorts if you need a a belt if you need
a wallet if you need a beanie if you
need a sweatshirt you need a hoodie hey
whatever you need if you need hunt gear
whatever you need
we got it for you we got a four units
made in America we got
factories where we're taking American
raw material and turning it into
American clothing
go to
originusa.com and get yourself something
that is made in America that you can
wear and not feel
overriding guilt because you haven't
enslaved poor third world Nationals that
are living in a sweatshop
being worked to death
don't do that let your conscience be
clear
originusa.com let your conscience be
clear it's true also we're representing
right this blue n equals Freedom good
if you want to represent go to
jockostory.com that's where you can get
your shirts and hats and hoodies that
kind of cool stuff
some new stuff I think coming down the
pipes
getting creative over the sun we come
down everybody just be on the lookout
for that one also the short Locker which
is one shirt new shirt every month
different design
every month you know creative I guess
if you want to call it they can call it
anyway a lot of people uh get some good
feedback on that one shirt Locker that's
what it's called it's on jockostore.com
it's a good one don't forget about
subscribing to the podcast Jocko
underground.com YouTube subscribe to
those psychological warfare
flip side canvas speaking of Dakota
Meyer Flipside canvas making cool stuff
to hang on your wall all the books look
uh Chad wrote Saving Aziz pick up that
book he also wrote a book called unfair
advantage and a book called fight for us
really good insights in these books
check them out also you got your Jocko
books Jocko publishing books only cry
for the living we also have the warrior
kid books Warrior kid five letters from
Uncle Jake it's out I should tell more
people that I did like an Instagram post
the other day yeah
telling 13 15 17 year old oh yeah
young men what to do with their lives
and you know some of the comments I was
reading the comments like oh oh you know
you're just saying this right now I was
like bro I wrote my first kids book like
seven years ago which had the same
Concepts in it there's no bandwagging
I'm jumping into
we're here to turn kids into Warrior
kids get the warrior kid books Mikey and
the dragons uh extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership leadership strategy
and tactics
go get that book actually on front we
have a leadership consultancy we solve
problems through leadership go to
ashlandfund.com live events are coming
up they're selling out we're kind of
oversold some of them
moving some furniture yeah squeezing
people in but
everything we do sells out so if you
want to come go to echelonfront.com if
you need help inside your company or
organization with leadership by the way
if you're having problems then you have
leadership problems if you have problems
with your supply chain it's a leadership
problem if you have problems with your
process that you have in place it's a
leadership problem if you have people
doing the wrong things it's a leadership
problem
all these problems with leadership
problem go to echelonfront.com we also
have online training
at the extreme ownership Academy extreme
ownership.com there's courses to take
you're not going to be a great leader if
you read one book or you sit through one
seminar you actually have to train just
like going to the gym extreme
ownership.com check that out and if you
want to help service members active and
retired you want to help their families
you want to help gold star families
check out Mark Lee's mom mama Lee she's
got a charity organization does
incredible things for veterans and
active duty actually sometimes so if you
want to donate or get involved go to
America's mightywarriors.org also check
out Heroes and horses.org we just got a
report from the field
it seems like at this time Micah Fink is
ice climbing
with a mountain lion that he just killed
after it attacked him but he survived
and now he's ice climbing to the top of
a peak to save a horse
hey also you got save our allies at save
our allies.org a great organization you
heard some of the work that they did
today they're continuing to do work
around the world support Mighty Oaks the
mighty Oaks programs.org sorry Mighty
Oaks program
dot org check that one out just doing
incredible stuff like I said these are
these are organizations that have helped
people that I know
so please help them in return and if you
want to connect with Chad go to Chad
roboshow.com also he's on social media
Chad robich show or Chad Robo Chad Robo
underscore official on his Instagram and
of course Echo and I are on there as
well where we're not we're not there to
draw you into the algorithm though
so be careful if you go in there but if
you want to find us Echoes at Echo
Charles and I am at
Jocko willink and thanks to Chad once
again
Chad thanks for everything you've done
and everything that you are doing we are
certainly grateful for your sacrifice
and your service and thanks to all the
men and women out there in uniform
who take risks every day to protect our
way of life and also thanks to our
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs dispatchers correctional
officers border patrol Secret Service
all First Responders
you also risk your lives
for us and we are thankful for that and
to everyone else out there
there's going to be ups and downs
there's going to be wins and there's
going to be losses and at certain points
you're going to come up against
powerful forces
or circumstances
that can overwhelm you
and what do you do when that happens got
a quick rule for you
do your best
simply do your best
and you do that by going out there
and getting after it
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko out